[Musique]
bonjour à tous salut Kevin comment
vas-tu salut à tous salut stouf ça va
très bien bien content de commenter
enfin cette demi-finale du speitchess
féminin puisque vendredi la technique
nous a fait fau bon et je ne parle pas
de toi Stouff ouais pour une fois
c'était pas de ma faute alors en fait il
y avait un problème sur chesscom les je
sais pas il y avait des bugs un peu de
partout je pense des connexions et du
coup ils ont décidé de d'annuler pour
pas qu'il ait de problème de lag c'est
vrai que ça peut ça peut vraiment porter
préjudice au joueur aux joueuses et donc
bon ça é reporté à aujourd'hui donc
aujourd'hui là il est il est 15h ça
devrait commencer donc à pour vous
rappeler rapidement je vais vous montrer
un petit un petit peu le Braet pour
savoir où on en est dans ce speed chess
féminin alors on on a IFAN qui a gagné
contre costenuk 12 et dem à 9 et dem ça
on l'a vu je crois que c'était jeudi
sIIT pas de bêtises c'était super ouais
c'était super très indéci d'ailleurs ce
match bien réalé costelou qui a mené
dans les deux phases de Blitz pour
finalement B s'écrasé un petit peu en
bulette avec ouifan qui a complètement
accéléré et a gagné ce match et donc là
on a quand même une autre demi finale
qui est très intéressante avec Caterina
lagno et Harik
dorev je sais plus son nom euh
dronavani dronav là voilà c'est ça je là
dronavali c'est çaonavalli harika et
donc harika qui est la numéro 2 indienne
depuis très très très longtemps et qui
est grand maître mixte et 2500 depuis
des années etina lagno qui est bon la
numéro 1 du tournoi bon
elle est numéro 1 mais je pense que oan
quand même en
hlo quand même plus d'élo
mais Catarina Lano qui aà été plusieurs
fois champion du monde de Blitz et qui a
un hlo de quasiment 2600 hlo feed c'est
quand même le top du top oui il a déjà
gagné cette compétition d'autant plus et
et c'est vrai que rien que son ch.com
qui est quasiment à 2900 que Harik c'est
plutôt près de 2700 bah ça veut dire
quelque chose on sait que quand on
s'approche des 2900 ça veut dire qu'on a
des réflexes de folie quoi tout
simplement c'est clair c'est clair et
donc a plutôt
2700 un petit peu moins de 2700 sur
chesscom donc un classement on va dire
un peu
standard mais c'est 2900 ça commence à à
jouer pas mal quand même sur chesscom
et mais bon après on sait pas parce que
tu sais qu'il y a a là il y a quand même
un incrément euh par rapport à B sur ch
quand on joue entre nous des fois il y a
pas d'incrément par exemple moi je me
considère comme extrêmement mauvais en
3+
1crément en fait c'est différent parce
que quand tu joues en un V Blitz en
IRL bah 3 + 2 ça va ça passe quand même
assez vite mais sur l'innet 3 + 2 je
trouve que c'est l'éternité quand tu
joues parce qu'en fait c'est ça oui oui
avec le on peut on peut prémover on peut
gagner vraiment du temps alors 3 + 2 en
réel pour avoir fait trou c'est une
galère quand même ben il faut appuyer
sur la pendule he et ça change toute la
donne faut jouer le coup et appuy jouer
le coup appuie et puis et pu le stress
te fait réfléchir un petit peu à chaque
coup et quand tu es IRL c'est pas le
même stress que quand tu es que quand tu
es online donc donc c'est différent et 3
+ 2 souvent on peut être en gros not par
contre sur Internet bon aussi he mais
c'est pas pareil et donc souvent les hos
qu'on voit je suis sûr que si tu met 3 +
2 dans toutes les parties obligatoires
je pense qu'il y aur plein de joueurs
qui auraient pas le même hlo parce que
le flag bien sû fait partie du jeu et en
3 + 2 ou 3 + 1 comme ici il y a beaucoup
moins de de de possibilités tu as raison
alors bonjour au chat salut benoint
salut Tommy Coto salut à tous n'hésitez
pas à nous saluer aussi sur le chat et
euh donc le temps va commencer
normalement là dans quelques instants
j'ai pas encore de de Start là sur slack
ni rien mais si tout va bien ça devrait
commencer j'espère qu'on aura pas de
fauses de pas de blagueis les puis les
joueuses les joueuses ont l'air prêtes
donc ça aussi elles
attendent pare et ça commence avec une
Espagnole
espagou
C5 peutêtre
aussi noirs le F C5 pour justement
contrôler
D4 et avoir une pression latente du du
Fou C5 qui va potentiellement se mettre
en B6 à7 et de loin contrôler la ce des4
voilà fou G4 ça reste assez fou G4 ça
empêche un peu des4 aussi assez logique
le cavalier qui est cloué la dame qui
défend le cavalier tout ça contrôle
aussi la case je vais faire des cases de
d'autres couleurs parce que le rouge sur
le rouge ça va être compliqué pour
suivre je vais essayer deer le clavier
désolé pour ce petit bruit on comprend
l'enjeu de de la position en tout cas
les Blancs jouent pour D4 et les Noirs
empêchent là et les deux C se
développent ouais ton cavalier je c'est
quand même un peu bizarre de la part des
noir j'ai l'impression fou en
g47 c'est pas très très commun
normalement mais elle a préparé ça pour
sans doute pour pour la session elle
savait qu'elle aurait le droit une
Espagnole et puis elle a préparé un
schéma qui va pas laisser beaucoup de
temps à à lagno qui qui qui va lui
demander justement uneap ation bon les
les joueurs peuvent pas vite se préparer
Souf s'il y a quand même peu de peu de
temps de pause
ouais alors cavalier 2 salut
Cécile bonjour à
tous alors cavalier 2 est-ce que vous
avez des un peu des des préférences dans
ce match est-ce qu'on sait une
prédiction on avait dit qu'on faisit une
prédiction la dernière fois je crois
ouais c'est vrai Stouff mais ça été de
courte durée ou j'ai du la du lait parce
qu'on a pas eu de match et tu tu te
rappelles que lagno avait les faveurs du
du
public j'avais dit ne Chan sur 10
qu'elle
gagne avait dit c'était un peu
d'ailleurs alors tu tu as annoncé 9
chances sur 10 que Catarina Lano
remporté ce match h du coup quand on a
fait la prédiction et ben il y avait
quasiment 100000 points de chaîne sur
Catarina grosse influence zéro sur Arik
zé zéro donc moi j'ai demandé aux gens
de parer quand même sur parce que si tu
Paris juste 1000 1000 points de chaîne
et qu'il a 100000 sur l'autre B tu peux
tout rafler en fait avec ta petite côte
quoi et on m'a écouté on m'a écouté et
et je crois qu'ils ont mis 10 points de
chaîne sur et ben j'espère que tous ceux
qui ont parer sur
sur sur Caterina vont trembler dans ce
match en tout cas on va refaire un petit
peu après les prédictions on va relancer
mais penseend un petit peu peut-être que
que les gens arrivent déjà avant ouais
il faut faut faire quelque chose D5
parce que F5 n'était pas jouable on
aurait eu envie de faire F5 mais il av
tout simplement prise G4
ouais petit pion bizarre et si je fais
E4 et souvent cavalier F4 donc c'est un
petit peu gênant donc peut-être qu'on va
faire T4 un jour en évitant bien sûr la
poussée
le4 cavalier F1 pour venir en G3 chasser
le fou plus envie de jouer côté noir
quand même avec
des pièces qui sont assez sympas ouais
moi j'aime bien les Noirs tu joues assez
actif comme ça éventuellement tu prar F5
voilà alors que les blancs ils ont jou
trois ranger et moins d'espace c'est
plus difficile à jeer pour les blancs là
on a les pousser F4 et E4 aussi côté
noir ça fait
peur peut-être avec un coup préparatoire
de dame D6 pour laisser passer la tour
A8
et ça peut quand même être
être un petit peu difficile pour les
blancs moi j'ai du mal avec mes ruptures
parce que E 4 il y a souvent bon il peut
y avoir prise il a aussi F4 il y a aussi
cavalier F4 il y a pas mal de de de
trucs possibles et fait le choix pour
travailler 5
ouais pour
enerinitiative salche salut passion
échec salut à toi fait plaisir de te
voir je pensais pas que tu allais venir
voir ce
match vu à ce que tu m'as dit la
dernière fois attention un cavalier
prend H3 discret cavalier prend F3 H3
pardon avec tour prend F3 qui qui qui
peut arriverfin attention il aussi Caval
des tro qui peut arriver bon on s'est
pas laisser prendre hein
ouais caval3 je suis pas obligé de
manger he peut juste tour
ici après je peux manger quand même
c'est vrai mais bon parce que qu D3 ça
attaque B2 aussi donc ouais il faut
manger peêtre tour D1 mais je perds la
colonne quand même il tour d qui va
arriver c'est pas pas génial
génial mais après bon des trois coups
naturels en tout cas que tu proposes
stouf ouais ça m'a normal bah tu vois la
Jae elle B tiens sympa ça a été joué de
la
Jae et fou prend prend ok Tourbin waouh
ouais donc ça veut dire que les deux
joueuses est tombé d'accord avec nous
c'est intéressant de voir
pourquoi pourquoi l'ordi n'aimait pas
parce que c'était vraiment le coup
naturel pour essayer de piquer la paire
de fou regarder juste le petit moment
parce que jusque là il y a pas eu de il
aime pas en fait il y a A4 mais si je
fais B4
ouais puis ouais il ve ah il y a du coup
il pas ou donc tu ne peux pas jouer
B4 ok bon c'est pas évident en blitz
donc on prend la colonne ouverte mais
les blancs réussissit à ouvrir une autre
colonne ouais et maintenant ce qu'elle a
fait con tu vois intéressant concept
tour suite B4 et A4 maintenant qui va
arriver ah oui
et ces P là qui vont être un peu faibl
est-ce qu'on peut enlever le module s
parce que du coup j'ai vu le coup
proposé d'ailleurs il y a tour pr F3
mais qui n'est pas de moi et et c'est
une bonne idée c'est pour faireour de ah
oui ouais c'était hyper mignon je
l'avais mis paf paf paf c'ests hyper
intéressant parce qu'on reste avec le K5
en l'air mais on a du
jeu une proposition
juste enlevant ça variante comme ça
tranquille et du coup cavalier E6 ben là
l'no elle a dû voir les idée à base de
A4 prochainement attention quand même à
tour prend F3 tour D2 sur cavalier E6
excuse-moi il s'est passé des choses ah
elle a fait he elle a fait t F3 ah mince
elle a raté l'no il eu ça intermédiaire
aïe AE aïe elle a raté complètement là
la phase
ouais voilà elle est complètement craqué
la dans les
tacti par rapport à mon ne chance sur 10
aïe non mais en face ça joue quand même
hein ah du coup je je vais attendre
quand même que remorte la partie pour
vous faire prendre les
prédictions voir si vous changez d'avis
salut yum salut salut salut coco salut à
tous mais là bam
tactiquement l'agno elle a pas été du
tout dans le dans le bon move après
pour se lancer tu vois première partie
on n pas chaud bien sûr on se rappelle
d'ifan d'ailleurs qui avait eu fait
vraiment un démarrage diesel puis après
était reparti complètement puis après
avait connu une situation un petit peu
difficile donc c'était vraiment ça
dépendait il y avit des des bonnes
séquences et puis après c'était l'un et
l'autre qui prenaent le dessus donc
c'était pas forcément évident bon là ça
commence ça va être cher c'est une pièce
nette de plus ouais ouais là c'est
abandon c'est abandon et
abandon avant deons cette partie on va
passer à la revanche partie numéro 2 je
vais ajouter le score et puis après je
vaèce blanche elle a elle a eu des
bonnes idées mais elle a raté l'idé tour
pr F3 donc les tactiques hein des fois
qu'on est concentré sur l'aspect
stratégique et on a le droit à un E4 E5
assez plat
ouais cette variante hein Stouff qui
fait pas rêver alors est-ce que je je
fais une petite prédiction alors je vous
rappelle rapidement l'histoire pour ceux
qui viennent d'arriver ce match devait
se jouer normalement vendredi et ce
match a été annulé pour cause de bug sur
le site chesscom et et donc on avait
fait une prédiction pour le premier set
donc je vous rappelle on a 75 minutes de
5 + 1 50 minutes de 3 + 1 et 25 minutes
de 1 plus une et du coup on avait dit
que enfin dans les prédictions que vous
avez donné vous aviez donné à cause de
Kevin qui lui était était vraiment pro
Catharina Lano euh vous avez donné 90
enfin 90 % sur Catarina et moi je vous
ai dit cétait quand même pas si clair et
pour l'instant Catarina est mené à zé
alors je vais envoyer la prédiction et
et je vous laisse vous faire votre avis
vous-même Plô écouter Kevin qui Kevin
vous savez qui il don encore
des
Paris Catarina elle est en train de de
vous attirer dans un piège elle a fait
elle a fait une un gros blunder tu vois
dans la partie d'avant euh et là vous
allez commencer à y croire et du coup ça
se passe ça se passera mal
euh bon je connais un petit peu la
position il y a rien du tout H6 ce qui
est bizarre c'est qu'on a l'impression
que les blancs peuvent faire foupr F6
mais il y a dame prend F6 et on joue la
finale avec les noirs avec les le le
rock destructuré mais c'est pas grave
dans la finale la souffle c'est la paire
de fou qui compte la tour B4 je crois
que c'est intéressant le le le coup pour
provoquer en fait le le fou H4 t B4 ça
paraît à toute façon c'est logique de
mettre un petit peu la presse j'ai lancé
j'ai lancé la
la la prédiction vous avez 5 minutes
alors apparment on me dit sur Youtube
que mon mon son est est loin et faible
et pourtant mon sonond normalement il
est ok attendez je vérifie juste mes mes
trucs
mais salutun rude on sera discret un
tour B4 jouet et et là la finale c'est
bizarre que Harik joue ça parce qu'on
sait que c'est il y a quasiment que les
Noirs qui
peuvent faire quelque chose alors c'est
en partie longue hein qu'on dit ça mais
normalement c'est plus facile à jouer
cette position avec les
Noirs il y avait une partie comme ça
dans la base doné que vous retrouverez
entre Jean-Pierre lerou et Laurent
Fressinet Laurent Fressinet avac
beaucoup fait
souffer fait
[Musique]
souffrir Jeanpierre le
rou du
coup trs agréable cette position pour
les Noirs il va falloir faire C5 C4 a 5
à4 on va travailler en tout
cas position connue pour être à sens
unique je comprends pas très bien le
coup A3 aussi
qu'est-ce que
c'est alors on a le pion à TR en l'air
et on se rattrape sur avec cavalier
prend6
ok c'est douteux parce qu'en plus il y a
des des thèmes avec A4 à certain
moment faut quand même que je trouve un
coup avec mon problème sur le fou6 ça
pose un problème
pratique ah peut-être C5 ah C5 c'était
très intéressant pour la
structure avec un piège je donnais le
fou E6 elle a peut-être raté C5 Catarina
lagno j'aurais joué Stouff non le fou en
E6 regarde juste avant elle vient de C5
et je voulais jouer ça avec le petit fou
H2
elle a raté je pense parce que du coup
C5 c'était le coup ouais là c'est
dommage elle a
complètement les deux joueux ont raté
pour l'instant elle a du mal à se mettre
en route tactiquement elle joue très
bien Catarina lagno mais dès qu'il y a
un petit tric tactique elle est pas
encore réveillée tactiquement ça va
arriver hein
ouais est extrêmement forte on rappelle
qu'elle est grand maître mix tout comme
son adversaire Arika
et un petit
ed bonjour à tous salut yukokun salut à
EV R qui est en télétravail je vais
appeler son son
boss et comment ça va le SU débutant aux
échecs j'imapendre plus sur le jeu et et
j'aimerais m'améliorer sur la leçon sur
le site
monbre bah super Yuko et bienvenue à toi
en tout cas tu sais que Kevin et moi on
on est entraîneur d'échec donc tu peux
déjà voir il y a nos YouTube respectifs
on nos chaînes de de de stream respectif
aussi et Kevin a aussi une une
plateforme en ligne où il met des packs
vidéos donc n'hésite pas en tout cas à
aller visiter tout ça allez yok que pour
toi je te mets le cadeau que j'ai
proposé 1000 fois je crois non allez une
dizaine de fois depuis qu'on fait les
les petits les petites chos.com si tu as
envie hop tu vas le voir et tu auras le
pack àadeau les autres vous pouvez en
profiter aussi c'est pour tout le monde
et on pourra faire des petits sauts au
pause on fera ça comme ça vous pourrez
aller voir différentes choses pour
progresser aux échacs et maintenant
cataril nagno a perdu sa paire de fou et
a quand même une finale de fou de
couleur POS légèrement difficile parce
que la structure n'est pas bonne elle a
pas vraiment de compensation maintenant
on peut penser que cette position va
faire nul quand
mêmeme pas mal de chance oui tant qu'
les
tour pas les tours ici match
nulchang prière tour il va peutêre venir
faire tour des
tour pour échanger la deè s'approprier
la colonne
et c'est vrai que avec la paire de fou
des Noirs il aur quand même des choses à
faire mais avec un seul fou chacun j'ai
pr une structure donc là les Noirs jou
pour pour la N
mais c'était une partie assez
soporifique quand même le début choisi
par est pour beaucoup elle a joué le
début le plus le plus pénible aux échecs
on va dire contre 4 5 un début souvent
choisi pour faire nul entre des grands
maîtres qui n'auraient pas trop envie de
jouer
et attention je pense que son choix pas
correct elle devra montrer autre chose
comme début pour er de prendre un petit
un petit plus est-ce qu'elle va répéter
son espagnol oui c'était cétait attendu
et je pense que voilà r ça s'est bien
passé la première partie donc elle va
jouer la même
chose elle a un peu changé l'or quand
même ouais elle avait pas joué avec
cavalier e7elle fait ça ça elle a fait
D6 ah tu vois elle a bossé plein de
petits schémas de d'espagnol avant son
match
vraisemblablement parce que c'est le
problème de l'espagnol on va dire à
niveau amateur c'est employé à très haut
niveau par les grands matres qui
connaissent les petits trics sur les
petites sousges mais quand un joueur
amateur joue l'espagnol avec les Noirs
c'est pas mal d'avoir des petites
sousignes stouf pour contit le joueur
d'espagnol qui ferait tout le temps son
plan un peu stéréotypé h on voit que
areka essaie de faire ça même contre une
grand maître
mixte et merci ye pour les petits mots
sympas en tout cas dans
ouais dans cette dans cette histoire ve
il veut son petit mot Yume ouais ouais
il veut il veut il veut il dit que du
bien parce que c'est un recopieur mais
bon ça on en parlera plus tard mais
euh non il m'a demandé de faire les
témoignage un témoignage pour un site à
lui et que que je mettre que je metre
qu'il est qu'il est très bien et cetera
donc je sais pas si je mettre la vérité
on va voir on va voir mais euh mais il
veut que je mette un petit mot du coup
il est genenstil avec moi tu vois parce
que il a besoin de moi pour une
fois sinon généralement il dit pas ces
choses-là il dit
pas mais tu l'as bien lu quand même tu
l'as bien lu mais je comprends je
comprends mais donc du coup
euh alors dame 8 alors l'idée ça peut
souvent être de ramener la dame en H5
par un moyen ou un autre et euh autre
idée de d 8 je vois pas trop trop on RAM
la dame par ici hein peut-être tour D8
tout simplement c'està-dire pour mettre
les pièces ouais voilà ok F les jou
toujours cette pression sur le pion D4
attendu tou on menace pour prend F3 et
en fait généralement dans ces position
les Noirs je pense que vont vouloir un
jour faire F5 mais j'ai du mal à faire
F5 maintenant qu' a une stension au
centre tu vois donc en fait je pense que
avec cette pression sur le pion D4
peut-être que les les Noirs recherchent
à ce que les Blancs fassent D5 pour
ensuite bouger le cavalier et plus tard
comme la position sera fermée et ben
balancer F5 un peu comme dans l'Est
indienne peut-être que c'est un truc
comme ça que qu'elle recherche harika
dans ses dans ses coups je sais pas
mais j'ai j'ai envie de lire comme ça tu
vois j'ai envie de le voir comme
ça D5 C qui va reculer on sa pas encore
où en E7 plutôt je mettrai mais en B8
c'est aussi une idée pourevenenir en D7
C5 prise
prise ce matin en train de jouer sur ch
après avir le son sur le cou du verger
j'ai vouu la mettre tique on décidé de
jouer en ligne moi je gagne directement
en faisant qure
coup
expérimenté et ben en fait moi je vais
dire un truc yokiokun
euh moi quand je faisais les tournois
quand j'habitais à Nice à l'époque ben
dans les temp jeune que j'organisais
j'interdisais le mat du berger tu le
fais tu perds parce qu'en fait pour moi
je trouve que bah c'est contreproductif
parce que tu apprends pas échecends à
faire un piège que si marche tu G donc
ça te ça te gonfle l'ego par contre si
tu perds ben en fait juste tu apprends
rien quoi c'est tu vois quand tu joues
une partie c'est bien d' d'essayer
d'apprendre des choses quand même aux
échec de progresser mais quand tu le
mets du verger ben tu apprends rien euh
que tu gagnes ou tu perds tu apprends
rien du coup moi je je l'interdisais
donc à tort peut-être mais moi je
voulais voir du du combat après si tu
perds on peut se dire que tu apprends
que il faut pas sortir la dame trop tôt
ouais mais en fait c'est un piège si ça
marche que veux dire mais si ça marche
pas tu as une position pourrie tu as BR
qu fois enfin voilà donc moi je je
l'interdis parce que je trouve que c'est
c'est c'est c'est juste pas comme ça
qu'on joue des ch moi je me souviens
d'un il y avait un enfant qui avait fait
un tour il av fait 5 sur 5 un
championnat qu'on avait fait à à
l'époque et donc il avait tout gagné et
puis à la fin la mise des prix et cetera
toutes les parties durer euh 30
secondes du berger il sort il
gag le voyz tous les enfants le voyaient
mais il est il g dans 30 secondes à
chaque fois il est trop fort ben non il
fait à chaque fois ENF il y avait aucun
secret quoi et euh et mais bon moi je
suis un peu contre ces chosesl c'est
pour ça que j'ai dit bon ok on va
arrêter ça ouais tous les animateurs et
entraîurs maintenant sont assez raccord
et ne le proposent plus c'est plutôt
quand on démarre les échecs par un canal
autre que le club pour ma part j'ai
commencé ma première compète sou j'ai
fait trois mats du berger euh voilà
j'étais hyper content évidemment et
rapidement benah on m'a expliqué que
c'était pas la bonne manière de faire
puis je l'ai vu par moi-même aussi mais
c'est vrai que première compétition si
on n pas appris en club voilà on a jouer
à la maison bah ce coup il paraît il
paraît vraiment bien parce qu'on gagne
rapidement mais après contre des joueurs
expérimentés même débutant de club bah
ça ça va déjà mal ouais non mais souvent
en fait c'est voilà c'est c'est les
parents qui dis tiens j'ai un truc et
cetera et puis il le montrent aux
enfants par que Ben tout simplement ben
le le papa ou la maman ben veut partager
un peu sa passion avec son fils et lu
donne un petit tric et c'est très bien
c'est mais mais c'est pas forcément
comme ça qu'il faut faire et le du
berger moi je suis complètement contre
mais voilà quand on débute complètement
c'est normal de de de de de regarder ça
en tout cas mais aussi savoir aussi
comment le contrer parce que comme plein
de gens qui qui le font en face faut pas
le faire mais si j'ai les Noir et qu' le
fait comment je réagis quand même bien
sûr et c'est important de voir comment
comment faire moi j'ai vu là sur sur les
réseaux il y a de partout tout le monde
fait des shorts sur comment par du j'en
ai fait un
aussi donc c'est assez
facile salut nal fait plaisir Deir ça va
très bien de notre côté avec une
Catarina lagno qui est en train de se
faire faire un petit peu bouger là les
Noirs ont réussi ce qu'ils voulaient ils
ont du jeu sur les rois et les Blancs
n'ont rien obtenu ils ont en plus des ce
faible en F3 H3 Stouff qui pourrait sur
long terme s'avérer décisive puis en
manque de temps avoir le roi un peu à
découvert c'est pas une bonne nouvelle
pour Catarina je suis en train de de
comment
dirais-je changer un petit peu mon mon
pronostic Stouff tu vois j'att tu vois
tu vois bon après ok il y a il y a eu
que deux parties c'est pas encore
terminé mais là on voit ici que les
Noirs ont accès au deux colonnes
ouvertes les blancs peuvent facilement
récupérer la colonne avec tour
mais ce qui voudrait dire que soit je
fais tour tour à pourer la colonne soit
j'échange et on aurait une colonne
chacun mais ta tour serait loin
maintenant du roi et une pression sur le
plan F2 donc à voir H4 cavalier H3 cali2
la grosse gaffe c'est gaff
ou pe
aussi fourchette mais euh vu que le
roouver ou a y a il y a les deux c'est
très intéressant d'AM pr F2 aussi j'aime
bien ouais mais je préfère quand même
changer les pièces tant qu'à faire ouais
ouais puis je regardais cavalier garder
les pièces justement et cavalier prend
F2 en plus il y aura du damage 3 échac
donc il y a pas de clouage véritable
ouais sur ça ça ça il y a pas de tour F1
parce qu'il a il y a ça ça qui nous dit
hein damage 3 ouais ouai c'est ça
exactement et et le pack du coup du
berger sur sur la plateforme non il y
aura pas le pack coup du berger sur la
plateforme je laisse je je laisse ta
au les shorts par exemple traité de ce
genre de chos voilà il nous a dit je
pense que c'est
mieux Nakamura l'a déjà fait hein
Nakamura l'a fait et euh je sais plus
qui c'était mais il a déjà fait en
partie lente E45 damage 5 et tu sais
aussi ça mais c'est intéressant tu sais
que j'avais regardé en plus c'est pas
bon c'est c'est modeste mais c'est pas
si bête h mais tu sais qui c'est qui l'a
fait aussi récemment
c'est Magnus Carlsen ah ouais ouais il a
joué au championnat du monde de Blitz C
à la ronde 1 ou la ronde 2 je sais
plus je crois qu' la ronde 1 il avait
perdu contre je sais plus qui ou f nul
et à la ronde 2 il joue en 2300 un MRE
feed et et il a joué E45 dans matage 5
magn c'est pas si et il a perdu et il a
perdu contre 2300 ah oui
ouis ça c'est un peu après ouais bon
après en face ça a bien joué et puis bah
voilà mais a qui a sacrifié il y a Reka
qui a sacrifié et puis ça paraît pas
hyper correct ouais apparemment c'est de
points d'interrogation mais il y a 15
secondes pour les blancs contre 1 minute
43 ah ro F1 maintenant il y a peut-être
des des chés avec où E4 existe non E4 ça
peut arriver ouais dame4 tour D2 dame F4
tour
D1 car ça l'air chaud et alors il y a
une super question de du poulet de
Belgique parce que que là c'est Toffre
un débat EU4 jouet Toffre un débat et on
va pouvoir en discuter à la miniause
d'aprèsptie parce que je pense que car
nagno va maintenant perdre assez
facilement trop mal au temps
h est-ce qu'il faut jouer des systèmes
ou pas quand on débute alors parce que
il y a toujours le conflit entre je joue
un système c'est efficace c'est moins de
travail mais par contre c'est moins
riche c'est moins riche que les grandes
lignes et du coup est-ce que
j'apprendrai pas moins sur le long terme
en fait je pense que quand vous êtes
débutant c'est vraiment pas bête de
jouer des systèmes moi-même je conseille
euh mais il faut pas que ça reste euh
pendant toute votre vie de joueur
d'échec démarrez par des systèmes pour
vous mettre un peu loin euh de vous le
côté théorique et de ne pas rentrer
surtout pas rentrer dans la jungle
théorique dès le départ mais jouer un
petit système où on est confort où on
applique bien les principes moi j'aime
bien l'idée euh mais après quand vous
avez un an d'expérience des fois 2 ans
d'expérience tout le monde ne progresse
pas au même rythme aller vers plus de
richesse et changer de système parce
qu'on peut aussi jouer plusieurs système
pour avoir la richesse on n'est pas
obligé de rentrer dans la grande ligne
euh voilà et ça dépend sur quel sujet
pour ma part stouf je lance ma première
sicilienne très prochainement euh donc
en début décembre sur la plateforme
alors que j'avais pas traité de la
cilienne parce que tu comprends bien que
c'est un sujet complexe ouais et j'ai
choisi une ccienne confidentielle euh
est-ce que est-ce que tu veux savoir
quelle sicilienne je vais traiter
encienne confidentielle sine
confidentielle je peux peut-être te
faire un petit jeu stouf de savoir
quelle sicilienne à ton avis j'ai
proposé pour tout le monde vraiment une
sienne qui va bien et qui est rare
extrêmement rare et tu connais forcément
alors est-ce que c'est la
sicilienne de notre match non non non
j'aurais pu mais typiquement voilà mais
il y a quand même beaucoup de choses euh
à connaître je trou AC pour bah ceux qui
voulaient se mettre à la sienne c'était
beaucoup dès le départ tu vois les les
lignes avec Roy F3 enfin tu vois c'est
c'est trop déjà de mon point de vue ou
bien s alors que on a qui qui qui joue
la la même ligne encore une fois alors
que c'est pas très bon pourtant et et
Katarina lagnol le sait que c'est pas
très bon donc elle retente de faire
gagner la paire de fou
mais elle mne au score je pense qu'elle
a elle a raison de de temporiser un peu
une position solide
j'ai pas mal il y en a pas mal qui qui
teste ben la CAN c'est c'est trop euh
c'est c'est c'est pas si petit comme
chant théorique ça aurait pu être la
okelli mais pour l'avoir joué youume euh
je connais pas mal de lignes qui euh
font suer la okelli donc j'ai décidé euh
de ne pas la montrer tout comme deux
cavaliers F6 sont des siennes
confidentielles mais qui sont pas tip
top de mon point de vue et et j'en ai
joué en plus cavalier F6 j'ai pas joué
mais la okell j'ai joué euh et j'aime
pas déjà pour moi donc je vais pas le
donner aux autres euh et en plus il y
avait une autre contrainte trouve je
voulais une cenne tu tu sais qui qui
soit dans la veine des schémas
classiques aussi voilà donc j'essayé de
trouver un système qui allait bien pour
tout j'ai j'ai pas eu encore le nom de C
cilien il y en a beaucoup des CEN aux
échecs he de toute façon pas d'idée
stouf je pensais que tu allais tu allais
me me trouver ça ça ça ça
te il a il a des connaissances quand
même des débuts un peu triquy dans la
cilienne is j'avais j'avais un très bon
pote qui plus très longtemps et c'est
pas bête c'est pas bête ouais ouais
ouais mais bon pour démarrer avec ça
c'est un peu chaud quand même toute
façon démarrer démarrer la sienne c'est
toujours chaud moi j'adore je joue ça
depuis toujours j' même des gens qui
m'écrivaient il me il me disaient Kevin
tu conseilles carocan tu conseilles
française mais tu fais pas de de pack
sur la cilienne alors tu joues la
Sicilienne ils étaent un peu jaloux tu
sais il pensaient que je cachais des
choses toutouf euh non timeanof toujours
pareil ça marche pas non n d'or c'est
trop
trop je joue le système de Londres ouais
ouais ben
je Guero c'est c'est un des conseils
j'aime bien système de Londres col car
pour démarrer et après vous êtes pas
obligé de jouer ça toute votre vie après
un moment comment pour cette hisire de
système ben je pense comme toi en fait
moi je pense que pour le débutant en
fait de base enfin ça dépend quel degré
de débutant mais quand tu es vraiment
vraiment débutant euh je parle pas
d'ouverture
euh ensuite quand tu commences à avoir
un bon petit niveau pas 7800 euh sur par
exemple et ben un petit système c'est
intéressant parce que ça permet vraiment
de savoir où placer les pièces avoir un
un plan de jeu général euh sans rentrer
trop dans la théorie et l'idée en fait
d'aguérir un petit peu tu vois c'est
vraiment d'essayer de d'avoir des
réflexes de vraiment t'améliorer
euh le je d'échec avec de base solide et
euh et une fois que que c'est bon j'aime
bien F4 ça empêche F4 que c'est assz
et et une fois que tu as réussi à faire
tout ça et ben changer éventuellement de
de de ligne ou de répartoir parce que
j'ai toujours la même chose c'est très
lassant moi j'ai des élèves qui me
disent ouais moi on m'a appris le lombre
maintenant je ve jouer autre chose et tu
vois on voit toujours la même position
et je peux comprendre qu'à la fin c'est
relou quoi tu vois donc tu as besoin
même toi de t'enrichir tu as besoin de
de de de changer un peu les choses mais
pour démarrer je pense c'est intéressant
complètement non mais complètement on se
je pense et c'est le c'est en bonne
intelligence l'efficacité dans un
premier temps et après la richesse quoi
mais c'est plutôt dans dans dans ce
goûtl et c'est hyper marrant la question
de Yuko tu m'as fait sourire
effectivement les règles sont les mêmes
sur Internet et sur un plateau réel
comme tu dis on a tu imagines que tu as
un sachet de pion et de pièces à côté
sur tout de pièces et que du coup si un
de tes petit pion se transforme euh en
que tu le promeux à à Dame souvent on
dit Prom promotion d'â mais bon tu peux
le changer en n'importe quelle pièce ça
peut être une autre promotion attention
à la tour aussi qui commen à manquer de
case finalement F4 a été
joué c'est un bon coup mais ça peut
aussi être un mauvais coup des fois par
que ça ça VO un petit peu le RO mais je
sais pas
trop le coup
que tu veux faire
mais
des tuis5 tu ouvres lui
là peutre est-ce que je joue fou F5 pour
essayer de d'échanger un
fou
jeux pas trop le chix en prime et là
joue tour D3 peut-être maintenant parce
que comme ça je vais enlever ta tour qui
manque coupil
exactement dans l'esprit de cette
position puis d'embêter la paire de
fou
pas
une s'appelle la
Snake qui est qui est pas connu la 6
Snake ouais je connais même pas tu
m'apprends un N autant je connais la
Snake la Benoni Snake tu vois et du
coup c'est un truc bizarre la avec je
sais plus tr comment c'est c'est avec 6
une sorte de avec une ligne avec 6 en
plus je suis pas mal sur les petits
trics et les petits trucs tu vois au
bout d'un moment j'ai vu pas mal de de
choses mais mais je connais pas je
connais
pas j'aimerais bien regarder du coup
ouais ouais mais bon alors je sais plus
laquelle c'est exactement j'ai un petit
doute mais c'est c'est une PO scè he
c'est avec c'est avec Ahou non mais tu
tu m'as roulé là tu m'as roulé mais ça
vraiment je non le poulet c'est pas la
Cobra la Cobra justement on avait fait
un match avec Stouff on avait beaucoup
joué donc ça il m'a c'est sa première
proposition à Stouff je sais très bien
et il essaie de il il essaie de de me
rouler dans les noms de de serpent
Stouff je pense qu'il essaie de de
m'avoir euh la CAL et la sèche non trop
théorique j'ai jouer cela en plus mais
trop théorique trop de choses et pas
assez dans l'esprit stouf je trouve de
la classique après il a la classique
hein mais la classique c'est oui mais
classique beaucoup de théorie quand même
beaucoup de choix on s'en approche hein
on on s'en approche mais et du coup vous
les cherchez encore ou au bout d'un
moment tu sais que sais qu'on a on avait
fait ensemble une belle partie à à Calvi
en 2009 ah oui oui oui j'avais essayé
d'ailleurs j'avais essayer de te rouler
avec un petit truc euh j'avais un petit
truc maison pas tu m'avais dit que tu
avais travaillé ça et moi je connaissais
pas jeéis en théorie au bout de de 7
coup et euh et bon on va pas raconter
une 1è fois ce qui s'est passé dans
cette partie
mais terrible terrible la p contre de ta
vie en plus je je savais pas que ça
allait me poursuivre
autant contrepère bon c'était la ronde
d'avant mais bon c'it dans un cadre
spécifique mais c'était la totale
imagine imagine je sais que je perds
contre le tricheur et après il il y a un
gars qui avait trichait c'était avéré
pour le coup ou ou oui c'est pas un
mytho avé non non non fois il y a plein
de gens qui disent tricheur et cetera
mais on sait pas là c'était vraiment un
gars qui avait Yello classement national
il na pas j depuis 25 ans et euh il
revient à la compétition et il fait une
norme de mare et une ronde avant la fin
d'ailleurs et euh et il démonte tout le
monde quoi c'est pas la la la partie où
tu vois tu vas gagner c'est vraiment
math à chaque fois c'est euh math en 20
coups contre tout le monde et le mec
trop fois et apparemment il avait il il
disait que cétait entraîné qu'il avait
fait plein de parties euh la
correspondance et
cetera mais non bon et d'ailleurs la
dernière ronde il est pas venu alors que
si ouais je me rappelle bien de ça c'est
ça me rendait complètement fumasse
l'histoire qui reviennent qui viennent
pas et tout ça
mais bon moi je pense c'est un c'est un
qui qui s'est joué à calville en Corse
et je pense qu'il avoir
menace non non mais tu viens pas quoi
hein tu viens pas dans la ronde
quoi je suis pas hyper sûr encore
pendant le tournoi parce que moi on
m'avait raconté que justement euh on on
lui avait proposé à l'époque avec les
dirigeants de la Ligue he euh de venir
faire un tour de Bliss avec les
meilleurs joueurs locaux et en fait il a
refusé cétait après le tournoi tu vois
Souf donc tu sais ils avaient envie d'y
croire hein franchement je me rappelle
de cette époque- làà où même soumet
s'était fait gronder par le président de
la ligue de de l'époque en disant non tu
t'assois tu peux pas accuser sans preuve
et c'était le premier tournoi tu vois
c'était hyper difficile tu te rappelles
ouais ce contexte bon où il
revenait en tout cas vous avez pas
trouvé ma sicilienne pour perdu une
caméra
là
coupque mais je me su même il y avait
champ de Paris Champion de Paris il a
fait 4 mois plus tard il a fait 9 sur
ne9 je crois 9 sur ne9 c'était après et
là les gens commenc à champion Paris
c'est moins de 2300 à l'époque ce
tournoi mais bon il y a quand même plein
de joueurs des ma F et cetera 2 80 enfin
il en a plein quoi et 9 sur 9 même quand
tu es un un fort grand maître il y a
peut-être des fois Nules que tu vas
lâcher ou tu vois je pense que même un
grand maître à 2600 ho il peut il peut
l'acher des nul hein même voir même voir
par une parti hein sûr mais euh mais
euh mais là 9 sur c'était assez
incroyable c'est suite à ça que ah rap
Coch c'est pas mal avec la la sienne fou
des7 qui a rare c'est suite à cela
qu'ils avaient proposé le tournoi un
petit peu la la rédemption si tu veux
Stouff en en comment dirais-je en
demandant à ce que qu' décou il vient
jouer des parti ah non c'est la pause je
suis bête une pause moi je me suis même
pas rendu compte il y a une pause au
milieu de chaque mais ouais mais Lano t
un petit E4 quand même histoire de si ça
passe ouais ouais ouais ouais du coup on
ouais je pendant la petite pause je vous
dis juste ah non tu as peut-être une pub
à lancer ouais mais t'inquiète on on a
plein de pauses donc et et du coup j'ai
choisi une et en fait il y avait un
petit indice c'était can échec Stouff
j'ai
remarqué j'ai joué une fois cette CEN je
l'ai joué en 2010 dans un national B
contre mon pote Jean-François jolie pour
le pour le surprendre Jean-François qui
qui est maître c'était une grosse partie
elle était géniale cette partie j'avais
fait nul mais j'avais failli me faire
mater et c'était c'était une partie de
dingue et j'ai remarqué que les petits
de canéchac les petits extrêmement forts
le petit Rajad maar le petit Timothé
razafraima je pense que Romu leur a
montré alors je sais pas c'est lui hein
mais j'imagine leur a montré une
Sicilienne et ça m'a donné envie de me
replonger dedans parce que je l'avais
joué à une certaine époque et je
l'appréciais bien c'est la
grivacee je sais pas le nom ça dit rien
ah bah c'est du coup elle est assez
méconnu c'est tu fais K6 une cenne ks6
hein voilà et euh du coup D4 prise D4
cavalier prend D4 et dame B6 juste pour
faire suer le cavalier D4 et après tu
joues un peu dans l'esprit de la
classique et je montre pourquoi on a
enlevé le cavalier de D4 comme ça les
blancs je peux le montrer jeux je peux
le montrer ouis si tu veux si tu veux
pendant que les
euh que c'est la pause ah donc ça c'est
une sienne ouverte et là on joue dame B6
on on vient embêter le le le cavalier
voilà exactement donc l'idée en fait
c'est que le cavalier ici est bien placé
en D4 et qu'on veut le mal placer on va
le mettre en en B3 et très souvent
derrière si pas de bêtises hein Kevin tu
me corriges hein on va jouer un plan du
style E6 à6
ouais et on joue reviendra parce qu'en
fait à un moment donné euh on va se
faire chasser alors je sais pas quel
ordre on aime bien faire cavalier F6 en
en premier en vérité prier ici direct en
tout premier ouais ok C3
E6 voilà et en fait dès que tu vas faire
F3 je ferai dame C7 dame C7 et et
après6 voilà s de c'est ça c'est ça et
le cavalier en C en B3 et il est mal
placé parce qu'il est il a pas beaucoup
de cas ici alors que en D4 ben j'ai t
les cavalier B5 les cavalier F5 et je
contrôle quand même beaucoup plus le
chquier depuis et tu vois j'ai fait j'ai
fait une des plus belles parties de ma
vie Kevin avec les blancs avec les
blancs sur cette ligne c'est vrai cétait
bon c'est une partie un peu moi moi
j'aim m appeler ça une partie
d'alcoolique
que poussé t t pS Tu es bien du sty à
pousser tous t pions elle est bien elle
est bien j'ai fait ça ça et j'ai fait ça
ça ça et et en fait c'était à à l'OP de
Barcelone
le le tournoi de sent qui se joue chaque
mois d'août donc très fort tournoi et
donc bon c'était à l'époque il y a y a
environ 10 ans où jeis bien ENF la fête
pendant le tournoi moi j'allais pas à
Barcelone pour faire le tournoi mais
plutôt pour les à côtés et euh et donc
sur un en plus était pas trop mauvais et
je jouis un grand mtre à 25 qu ch
et euh alors cherche ma table tout table
TR comme ça cherche ma table don
j'arrive en retard à la partie de 10
minutes environ marrant et je cherche ma
table et je trouve pas et en fait il y
avit une petite scène avec retransmis
mais quand tu es 30è 30e table benah tu
joues pas sur les Ch tu vois il avait
une dizaine quoi tout à fait en fait mon
adversaire c'était le champion catalan
donc il avait sa table à titré et donc
je cherchais R plus 5 minutes à chercher
ma table je demand à l'arite me dis tu
joues là je dis ok j'arrive à la partie
et le mec il me joue ça et euh donc pour
moi il éit 16h du
matin un petit peu dans quel état je je
me sentais et en fait je tout envoyé
envoyé et j'ai j'ai fait une partie
c'est marrant parce que on joue à côté
de de joueurs à grand m à 2006 200650
qui é à côté de moi et en fait il y
avait un troupeau de monde qui qui était
au retour d'une par
dans cette zone de rransmission c'était
la mienne c'était Laar rien à [__]
rstein à côté rien à [__] les les
grands matres en 2006 c'était moi parce
qu'on avait une partie il y avait tout
en prise et c'était très très marrant
comme partie ah j'adore cette ligne là
j'ai fini par perdre parce que j'ai
gagné je c tu gagné non j'ai fait une
alu j'ai fait une alu de enfin à la fin
en fait on on avait 15 secondes pour
enfin 15 15 coups à faire avec 30
secondes à la pendule ah et j'ai fini
par craquer sur une tactique à deux
balles au
39e dans une position complètement
gagnante et je luiavais tout mis euh et
c'était marrant j'avais sacrifié la dame
c'était vraiment un truc de fou et euh
bon je perds et à la fin j'étais quand
même content de la partie que j'avais
fait parce que j'avais fait un beau
spectacle quoi tu vois oui ou oui oui
bah c'est c'est les belles parties de
combat euh voilà donc j'ai perdu mais
j'étais satisfait j'éis satisfait et
donc bon le gars il est grand maître
20550 moi j'avais euh 2003 tu vois bon
ok j'avais rien à G ouais tu veux la
ligne de puncher en plus voilà ligne qui
envoie tout elle est hyper intéressante
et à la fin la partie je lui je lui
demande si s'il va analyser parce que
franchement j'ai une grosse partie quoi
j'étais content de moi ouais ouais et il
me
dit d'une manière très insultante il me
dit mais qu'est-ce que tu veux analyser
quo et alors là je dis ok bon toi tu es
hein pas très sympa quoi et euh surtout
si tuas si tu asroqué en plus c'est pas
très cool normalement c'est pas lui de
des choses qui étaaiit pas forcément
très correctes mais c'était tellement
dur en pratique et ouou envoyit les pion
c'est c'est la ligne chaude hein pour
avoir regardé avec l'ordi c'est c'est
très intéressant mais en cas tout à
l'heure s'il y a une petite pause je te
la montrerai rapidement en accéléré a
plaisir avec plaisir on parce que parce
que c'était vraiment bon vraiment en
accéléré hein c'était vraiment sympa
comme partie mais il m'a dit le gars le
gars à la fin il dit mais qu'est-ce que
tu VASER tu tu as fait n'importe quoi
genre et euh et bon bah j'étais triste
hein du coup pas très sympa quand même
ouais ouais alors que en plus ou toi tu
as gagné bon juste c'esttil quoi des
joueurs déch catégorique en plus tu dis
pas ça enfin il y a plein de trucs qui
vont pas mais bon non mais en fait moi
je considère que si tu fais une perce tu
aurais dû lui coller tu aurais d lu
coller si je fais une paire genre moi
j'ai 2300 je BS un grand mtre à 2005 et
je l'éclate ok si je lui propose à
d'analyser à la fin c'est pas forcément
à moi de le faire parce que j'ai gagné
tu vois ça me monre ouais bien sûr ouais
mant je t tu une leçon à l'analyse lui
il me propose analyser vu qu'il est plus
fort que moi je pense à laavenir de lui
tu vois mais là j'ai perdu la partie
j'ai fa oui tu as perdu donc tu peux
demander ça ouais il est censé te faire
plaisir quoi il est pas censé te mettre
bon désolé j'ai pas le temps je dois
partir quoi faire je sais pas moi pas de
sou mais me disent comme ça qu'est-ce tu
tuas rien compris j'ai j'ai pas du tout
apprécié tout à fait je je peux
comprendre effectivement alors tu
m'apprends quelque chose ça s'appelle
aussi la Godiva j'espère que je ferai
jamais de quiz avec toi parce que tu as
l'air assez calé sur les noms
d'ouverture non mais yum il est il est
très très bon avec Google aussi hein pas
trop trop ah ou
Godiva je connaissais pas je connaissais
pas tu peux tu pourra nous expliquer
d'ailleurs pourquoi s'appelle la Godiva
ça m'intéresse euh et et le poulet de
Belgique tu as tout à fait raison mais
ça ça c'est sur n'importe quelle
sicilienne que vous jouez vous devrez
vous former aux Antill euh sicilienne on
peut citer la lapine fou B5 le rolimo
est spécifique à cavalier C6 comme tu le
dis mais il y a aussi des fous B5 échec
les attaques canal par exemple sur euh
les siennes D6 donc finalement le joueur
de cilienne doit se former aussi sur les
anticiciliennes avant cela il doit avoir
quand même sa propre sicilienne
évidemment et là on a encore un nouveau
nouveau schéma
avec c'est assez bizarreession tuas pas
de S bon des qui a été joué ouais il y a
toujours un truc elle joue des petits
trucs tricky des sccienes très
confidentielles mais j'aime bien j'aime
bien après sur cavalier
E7 on doit faire effectivement c'est
c'est D4 mais si c'est pas D4 et C3 sur
cavalier E7 qui est intéressant aussi
bon bref là ça a l'air on a l'air de
rentrer vite dans le vif du sujet j'ai
une question Kevin qui n'a rien à voir
mais une fois on était en stream et tu
m'avais tu m'avais donné une petite idée
de truc jouer sur E5 sur E45 ah oui ou
oui je l'ai revu au d'ailleurs av
ave44 coup juste les TR
premiers c'est une viennoise car C3 et
D4 et je l'ai vu au capdag un jeune
maître français jouer
ça Arthur Lucas il a joué le système que
j'appelle système m c'est M qu' l'
popularisé en le 21 donc c'est assez
récent c'est une sorte de partie du
centre où tu commences avec kc3 et après
tu mets ta dame en D3
ok donc tu fais E4 E5 cavalier C3
cavalier F6 D4 ed dame D C C6 dame D3
idé fou F4 grand RCK
OK et c'est hyper intéressant ce qui est
marrant c'est que j'ai joué ce ce joueur
Arthur Lucas dans le tournoi donc ça m'a
traversé l'esprit de jouer E4 E5 sauf
que je l'ai vu dans le tournoi sur sur
E4 C5 il jouit aussi D4 avec Dame prend
D4 et dame D3 donc bah j'ai préféré
jouer la Sicilienne parce que c'est
quand même beaucoup plus confidentiel
encore et euh il y avait une super
partie de corobof dans les bases de
données et ça m'a plutôt sourri mais il
est assez marrant ce joueur Arthur Lucas
et d'ailleurs quand il l'a joué sur45 il
a mis une raclé un jeune que j'aime
beaucoup qui est très fort le triple
champion de France de catégorie pupi
Benjamin trévisiol qui est aux environs
2200 et euh et Arthur lu réussi une une
belle partie avec ce système que je
viens de te citer qui est excellent pour
les joueurs agressifs OK et pas beaucoup
de théories donc c'est ça peut être
intéressant de regarder oui non pour des
fois tu as des surprises moi je joue
plein de trucs sur 45 mais je joue plein
de trucs qui à la fois plein de choses
et et pas grand-chose ouais je comprends
et euh beaucoup de choses mais pas
précisément quoi voilà après ce que je
joue de manière un pe plus dire euh un
truc que je joue vraiment
le mieux c'est l'c et là je suis capable
de jouer plein de varantes différentes
de l'c donc ça dépend de mon adversaire
des fois tu sais il y a du H4 rapide il
y a des
lignes en H4 il y a plein de trucs
différents donc j'ai plein d'idées de
partout j'ai plein d'idées donc du coup
c'est pas évident mais même moi je men
sens jamais donc il faut que je la
recheque à chaque fois mais bien sûr
bien sûr des fois avoir des idées même
le grand du centre grand du centre E45
D4 bien sûr en faitép pour être si bon
mais il y a des idées
avec jouer ça quand même donc la dame tu
la mets en
E3 et après après tour E8 il y a le
grand coup c'est dam G3 connaître bien
sûr mais il y a dam F4 aussi assez
intéressant qu' avait bien sûr et donc
bon coup ça peut être triqu tu sais des
fois sur une partie bon on va dire que
là la ligne avec dam des 3 je pense que
c'est une partie du centre amélioré
honnêtement pour l'instant j'ai pas
trouvé enfin si j'ai trouvé une ligne où
c'est à peu près égal mais franchement
les nom noir
euh ils ont quand même du travail en
plus si les gens connaissent la partie
du centre ils vont mettre leur fou en B4
comme sur dame 3 si tu veux oh là
attention apparemment gros bler
attention il y a un mat en G7 he qui
menacé ouais ça l'air pas mal en plus c
un F des4 qui a l'air assez intéressant
fou des4 et ça serait
magnifique elle rate les tactiques
malheureusement et si tu défend pe avoir
damage 3 non
bah oui c'est ça tu as trouvé F
bravo si jamais
[Musique]
on
inér
c'est voil donc ça ve dire l'autre coup
un peu logique de la
[Musique]
position bien donc ça veut dire que ça
cale tactiquement pour tout le monde
parce que c'est pas des positions
faciles et oui euh effectivement coco il
y en a beaucoup qui aimeraient jouer la
sienne mais c'est assez difficile
c'est la raison pour laquelle d'ailleurs
je propose des choses un peu plus
confidentielles que la sienne nagedorf
qui qui est très bien mais très
difficile ou la chfessnckof la
calashniikov on a entendu beaucoup de
noms de siciliennees il y en a beaucoup
mais des si une facile à jouer je pense
qu'il y en a pas mais il y a qui sont
plus faciles à jouer que d'autres bon on
voit que c'est le festival de
par est compleuss on peut le
dire ça elle va peut-être voir je sais
pas c'est presque plus naturel de faire
le Bage des des
cavaliers est pas agressé elle est pas
agressé donc là maintenant elle agresse
c'est logique alors que tout à l'heure
elle était agressée elle a réagi
défensivement wou
cant voilà là cavalier hf3 cavalier hf3
damage 3 ça pas mal mais cavalier H3 il
y a pas tour G1
ou si est-ce qu'il a tour G1
oui mais bon on peut continuer quand
même le travail eu peut-être qu'on prend
pas en G1 tout on va jouer je montre
juste que je peux pas damage 3 faut des
qu prend des qu il y av cavalier F3 euh
Arnaud
ça fait mal dame F5 c'est bizarre de pas
jouer dame H3 ouais pour damage
3 ok bon ça fait une menace quand
même tour g c'est gaffe sur gaffe mais
bon ok c'est pas si simple encore une
gaffe là va y avoir un problème avec
ouais mais je comprends rien en fait ça
va c'est la position compliqué ou
ou on on va tricher un petit peu 2
minutes ouais mais ouais il y avait
cavalier h F3 c'était quandme le coup
logique ou il a un problème là-dessus
ouais hf3 c hyper
logique et là tuant
ouais là tu vas perdre du
matériel mais ok bon c'est
ouais c'est une partie de pingpong là en
tout cas lagno elle a alors peut-être sa
partie éit moins correct que ce qu'elle
a pu faire avant mais au moins elle joue
très vite ouais et depuis qu'elle joue
très vite B on prend tout en F5 Stouff
et on gagne et tour g ça va être abandon
voilà ça continue encore un petit
peu
tac tour F3 attention au fou peutêre fou
F6 le Fou est très bien F6 va contrôler
D8 on aura plus qu'à qu'à pousser
là-haut ici t D1 bon ok là c'est c'est
abandon sur tour là j'ai tour3 qui va
mat ici t ailleurs
je6 ça va être
abandon abandon ça va permettre de
revenir
pression ça aide tout simplement
pointit n donc là 32 d'un coup dans ce
match lui faire du bien alors que la
partie était pas très correcte
ce qu' peuvent faire même si elle était
très compliqué c'est pour ça que
ah oui d'accord on a le droit à une
petite italienne elle change
har de son système qui pas très bien
marché d'ailleurs
et décide de jouer le le confidentiel
fou7 et la poussée du pion a est un des
thèmes
classiques où je mets mon fou dans cette
situation
en B3 il y aurait cavalier D4 ça en A2
il cavalier B4
ouais dans ce cas-là je le mettrais bien
en A2 je me poser la question de savoir
si on peit prendre en A4
ouais moi je pense pas je pense que
c'est plutôt5 tout le temps ouais est-ce
qu'on alors fou des5 a encore cavalier
des 4 sauf ce qui est un peu
embêtant ça marche c'est
fou pere qu'elle connait très bien aussi
ouais donc peut-être donc j'ai pas de
place avec mon fou qu'est-ce qu'elle
peut jouer
alors4 pour oui mais
P pas grandose j'arrive
pas il y a eu de lae on laisse ça paraî
logique bien jouéaime
bien ok fou3 pourtant c'est légitime de
vouloir enlever ce cavalier des cartes
c'est B3 aussi reste d'être d'être une
idée
intéressant c'est plus facile pour les
blancs cette position quand même ou
voilà voilà on s'y attendait cavalier
les blanc les Blancs ont un bon
plus parce que le cavalier est bien
stable et le fou s'exprime pas trop le
fou noir peêtre un jour le placer en D4
mais
ouais et C3 c'est un coup j'ai pas trop
envie de faire à cause du P D3 donc ça
dépend oui tour D1 pour commencer et
voir un peu comment comment on joue
j'aime bien aussi son petit A5 A6 pour
taper un peu sur la
structure dame D5 là il faut garder les
dames je pense B c'est même sûr he si tu
prends puis on prend le cavalier va
déloger et je peux pas me permettre de
doubl les pion ici dam F5 T 4 c'est une
idée derrière
ramener la tour par
là-bas prendre sur ce blanche ou C5
maintenant si on fait ass sur B5 et le
cavalier perdra belle cas en C4
attention là les noirs sont en train de
s'organiser on arrive à faire je sais
pas G6 F5 ça pourrait être intéressant
attention pion E5 mais on va
pouvoir se mettre en
place
trop compliqué là T
4 devient dev intéressant et merci
beaucoup la pour le pour le
raid est-ce
que est là non il est pas là merci
beaucoup allez voir
son sa chaîne attends est-ce
que
favori
voilà merci beaucoup en tout cas pour le
raid c'est cool
to1 alors tour G4 et mainant le vous
voyez le Fou est arrivé en D4 sa
meilleure case les Blancs n'ont pas
beaucoup progressé et l'agno propose
l'échange de dame pas très apprécié de
la jauge mais on s'en fiche normalement
le tandem tourfou marche mieux donc elle
a les réflexes
je pense taper sur
le il faut faire B5 est-ce qu'on a le
droit de faire un coup comme B5 pour
enlever ce C4 qui est
thématique pour B
évidment mais pour
refireusement ouais tour des5 a été joué
attention ce petit pion qui peut être un
jour en l'air et sur F4 est-ce que tu
veux jouer non tu veux pas jouer F5
quand Mme ouais je peux
jouer pourquoi tu veux pas jouer F5
c'est intéressant quand même j'ai peur T
2 e F4 tour7 c'est ça compliqué aussi
hein compliqué très comp parla de
ça je sais pas parce qu'il y a du F3 il
y a
du il y a du B5
encore
trèsile que c'est pas si grave
d'avoir d'abord et le Fou est
parti devient une men la tour
le pour
défendre ici
pas réussi à profiter
du cavalier C4 qui était fort mais les
Noirs ont juste amélioré plus de coups
d'amélioration alors qu'il reste 24
minutes hein dans cette période de 5 + 1
et ensuite vous savez qu'on enchaînera
avec une période de 50 minutes en 3+ 1
pour finir avec du 1 + 1 pendant 25
minutes ouais là ça commence
à être vraiment important dans cette
période de 5+ 1 d'encaisser pour
l'agno qu'elle a souffert
quand même
ik elle a raté un gros coup dans la
partie d'avant elle aurait pu prendre
plus 3 ouais mais souvent c'est un peu
ça on parla un petit peu la dernière
fois du
moral quand tu
voà Catarina qui pouvait perdre par
d'avant qui finalement réussi à la
gagner au final ben ça peut lui donner
un petit coup de motivation un coup de
boost et ça peut aussi faire planchir un
peuik le fait de rater des trucs et
cetera donc
bien sûr tout cas pour l'instant je
trouve que Catarina elle joue pas
vraiment euh
elle joue pas comme il nous habitué oui
à son meilleur niveau mais elle peut
elle peut monter en pression surtout
tactiquement elle a raté des choseselle
ne rate pas d'habitude vraisemblablement
h
elle joue bien stratégiquement dans ses
parties mais elle rate des choses
tactiquement T 4
[Musique]
alors depuis que a été jouéuis qu'ass a
été joué c'est que le cavalier a pris de
la puissance enfin a pris de la de
la la puissance en C4 C Quême très fort
il est indélogeable par personne sur B5
a toujours la présente passant je vous
rappelle un prend B6 donc faut quand
même faire attention à pas perdre ce
pion c'est quand même
dommage tour des7 jouet plutôt un bon
coup faudrait réussir à mettre en place
E4 h ça va ri péter hein j'ai
l'impression mais j'aime bien les blancs
quand Mme je trouve que les Blancs
peut-être je sais
pas ce cavalier en fait il me fait
vraiment plaisir ça fait
nul Catarina qui aura les
[Musique]
blancs pas très dangereuseik avec avec
les Blancs ouais elle joue juste trois
parties avecikve avec les Blancs c'est
tro nul les parties décisives c'est
quand Catarina à à les blancs elle a été
plus plus ambitieuse mais ça elle s'est
fait aussi retourner mais elle a du
style dans ce qu'elle fait Harik avec
les noirs avec les Blancs elle joue des
parties sorifique c'est un peu bizarre
tu vois elle prend presque des risques
avec les noirs avec des des lignes un
petit peu bizarroïes c'est comme si noir
avec blanc des lignes hyper hyper plates
quoi alors que là c'est quand même autre
chose ce qu'on voit avec la noire c'est
c'est un réel parti prix plutôt le le le
goût du risque c'est vraiment rigolo
ouais G4 va arriver avec la pression sur
B4 la pression habituelle alors
peut-être le fou en B6 ouais alors
est-ce qu'on peut jouer fou G5 je sais
pas dame D5 peut-être
ouais je jouerai pas F6
là sur fouage sur ça je ne joueris pas F
là peut-être je joue
B4 B4 B6 et fou G5 j'avais envie de
d'embêter la dame parce qu'elle avait
pas beaucoup de bonnes
cases bon après alors est-ce que là j'ai
droit de jouer D5 ouais D5 c'est logique
pour essayer de prendre de l'espace et
on échange et on joue F F4 tour C1 ouais
c'est logique on met une petite séquence
de coup piquan c'est vrai que j'aime ça
les coup piquan prise d'initiative et on
y va alors les Noirs vont peut-être se
venger avec eux-mêm fou F5 pour essayer
de d'enlever le cavalier voilà tous les
coups ai un coup marrant alors qui n'a
pas été du tout joué je sais pas du tout
ça marche F5 ah F5 ouais ou ou ouais je
te reconnais bien là avec des petites
bah ouais les petitesti hein si je peux
gagner une pièce moi j'y vais he mais
après euh la j pas forcément très
d'accord il y avait toursien qui était
rigolo mais il y a F4 dommage c'est D6
tu as raison je pense ouais mais bon D6
c'est chaud hein à D6 euh puis on prend
tout simplement
ouis encore ça j'ai pas donc ok non
alors F5 qu'est-ce qu'il faut jouer F5
on va trouver quand
mêmeer D6 av une part de raison D6
fallait faire attention tout ça
aussi c'est
sympa5 ou
B3 ces positions sont à jouer avec les
Blancs généralement a le P va être fixé
on va avoir bon cavalier contre mauvais
fou c'est une structure qui fait penser
à une partie de de chirof contre
mvl je sais plus à quel tour c'était
c'était l'année dernière je sa plus à
quel tournoi c'était mais une structure
un petit peu similaire je dis pas de
bêtises m même d'ailleurs mvl blanc
d'ailleurs quel le tourno c pas c'était
pas un grand Suisse un truc comme ça pas
cette année l'é d'avant un truc du style
peut-être en tout cas elle a réussi son
coup encore à les
noirica avec les Blancs j'ai pas aimé sa
prestation avec les noir j'ai adoré ce
qu'elle avait fait c'est vraiment un
gros contraste h non
des choses hein c'est clair qu'elle elle
a des idées dans les ouvertures mais
juste avec les noirs elleé que les Noirs
dit bon les blancs bien mais après
peut-être que pour le Bullet et cetera
elle a prévu autre chose he que là elle
est en Phe de test un petit peu pourquoi
pas tout à
fait alors tour
C3 donc tour3 peut être une idée
clairement elle veut essayer de doubler
sur la
colonne je sais pas comment est-ce qu'on
peut continuer d'ailleurs avec ce c'est
pas si facile ok sans doute toujours
pareil dans ses positions on sait pas
trop quoi faire peut-être jouer la pièce
qui ne joue pas t D8 ça peut pas être
mauvaische coup piquant en plus avec la
prise B2 qui était
envisageable il regarder lesûs alors je
dire une
bêtise là c'est chaud c'est pas une
égalité basique c'est une
positionc
pas tout à l'heure et donc fou C de
peut-être j'ai fou les trois plus tard
décou un petit peu pour chasser la dame
t B2 en l'air faire attention mais là
c'est ch un coup pour attendre je pe t
vite normal qu'est-ce
qu'on est-ce que
H 4 peut être un coup H4 c'est c'est
vraiment je regardais ce genre d'idée je
trouve ça hyper rigolo essayer de ch
pour mangour ouais et si tu manges là
j'ai toujours pour j'ai tris donc ça va
hm hm H4 j'aime ouais super c'est
H4 H4 H5 et si le gar il F8 pour
défendre H7 et ben il V a joué dynamique
avec Campion isolé là il y a beaucoup de
motifs qui apparaissent et elle est
mieux autant et dans ces cas-là elle a
elle a prouvé qu'elle était forte ouais
B4 ok étrange
elle est vraiment dans un esprit très
stratégique fixation et compagnie il y
avait beaucoup cou rigolo à regarder H4
que tu proposais vraiment le coup
basique de ce genre de position en
plus je pensais je pensais qu'elle hésit
avec tour C7 fou C7 fou C7 a Glid D6 D7
c'était chaud et j'arrivais pas trop à
évaluer mais ah bah là est-ce que je
peux toujours le faire B non il y aura
tour F6 tu veux faire ça toi ouais mais
sans tour F6 parce que T F6 là c'est
embêtant heureusement qu'elle a ce tempo
par que c'est un coup de bol
vraisemblablement que là c'est dur de
tout anticiper avec une 49 la position
des noirs
ou ou là
intéressoup est tour dans l'idée
pas tour commence à être vraiment sympa
ou c'est super al est pas d'accord mais
ouais ça va il a la la la chuge est
bonne comme on comme on dit maintenant
mais ok fou D 3 H4 derrière ça et sur ça
est-ce que je veux quand même euh
H4 Mo j'ai envie cavalier F8 maintenant
donc H4 H5 je gagne une piè mais il y a
il y a quand même le le fou pr G3 que tu
as indiqué avec tour F6 quoi une menace
peut-être qu'on peut s'en prémunir avec
un petit fou D3 pour enlever la dame ah
bah tour3 sympa aussi
on enlève la dame qu'on fait rajoute fou
des3 et après on envoie un
H4 tour pas mal tour c'est sympa prend
pu on prend tour F6 et je sais pas trop
où je vais encore mais peut-être dame D3
on a le droit de proposer aussi
l'échange de dame ouais oua ouais avec
le cavalier complètement dominé dès que
tu as une pointe en G3
ouais pas de cas il va mettre du temps à
se recycler et puis quand on a le F en
D3 on peut faire des A4 on peut faire
pas mal de choses bon fou B3 jouer ouais
j'e bien fou B3 parce que des fois il y
a des idées paraît il y a des F7 avec
des des idée de tu sais tac tac et mat
un petit peu arrivver he elle joue assez
vite elle pose des problèmes pratiques
c'est pas mal ce petit dambé de fourbe
avec le pion à3 qui traîne est-ce qu'on
peut le bouffer c'est pas sûr mais
menace de menacer sm fait peur avec peu
de
temps je joue H4 une nouvelle fois
est-ce que j'ai le droit H4 tu vas faire
fou G3 et tour g tour f6our pr tour F6
ouais dame C2 forcé je pas obligéfendre
non plus je
peuxmeilleur quand
même de
tranquille protège à 3 moi
est tendue cette dernière partie reste
minutes qui fait que on peut se dire
qu'après cette partie là il y aura un
blitz vraisemblablement sauf si la
partie est
expéditive vont aller au chos avec le
plus une seconde et sur tour
F6
une je mets bien4 moi pour jouer tour
B3 le problème c'est que à chaque coup
on vous voyez qu'on a plusieurs
décisions on est obligé d'aller très
très vite dans chaqueamp faut pas se
laisser trop distancer
autant peut-être dame C3 et je joue la
petite finale contre le pion C7 ouais
c'est pas mal avec A4 derrière bon plat
mais bien les dames voilà elle a
travaillé voilà d C3 c'est logique elle
joue vraiment comme ça depuis le
départ
mais c'est mieux là c'est un problème
quand même tour D8 c'est bien joué pour
essayer de contrer encore quand même
tour C7 on échange tout tour C8 tour A8
ça va être dur maintenant pour
ouais tour prend tour tour C8 tour A8 et
on amène le fou en
B7 fa prend7 mais
ouais je préfère jouer tour à8 pour la
finale avec le fou j'aimerais bien le
garder ça il y a de fortes Chan de
nul parce que oui ça c'est très bien
c'est on pique le à coup s sur le pion
A6 et si on gagne B5 on a gagné a eu
point d'interrogation sur tour PR 6
qu'on aurait quand même tous joué
peut-être qu'on pourrait faire fou4 fou
B7 plus précis pour aller chercher avec
le
fou ok là il Chan de gain quand même
mais attention ouais pas attention c'est
pas si facile F3 il av aussi tour d G4
qui ouais c'est bien jouer F3 j'aime
bien ça prend c c technique notre fou
ici peut-être G4 voilà G4 j'aime bien
aussi Caval C4 cavali puis cavalier3
cavalier3 fourbe cavalier3 c'est pas
trop grave j'ai F4 donc on va essayer de
se concentrer sur peut-être cou C6 A4 ça
c'est souvent le
coup4 commence à avoir un peu de jeu là
ouis et je me rappelle avoir échangé un
pion comme ça une fois autour can dans
ce dans dans une position tendem tour
fou contre tour et ça a écouté le
demi-point parce que si on gagne B5 on a
deux pions passerouff et le pion B5
était très faible bien sûr les blancs on
encore un petit petit avantage mais il
est en train de de fuir et oui attention
faut faire presque attention avec les
les blancs
des4 ok a commen à sentir qu'il fallait
pas trop déconner et attention cavalier
E2 ah oui il y a cavalier prend B5 a
oubl nul ok nul on assure la nul voyant
que ça déconna bon faut pas 3 contre de
normalement même en crise de temps va
jouer assz vite elle peut jouer beaucoup
de coup ça va être trs trs temps la
pendule
toujoursou plus une
seconde mais bon il a pas trop trop de
manière de progresser avec même si G5 tu
vaschanger les pions et plus pion plus
en fait tout à faiton
a aucun risque donc en plus elle
[Musique]
m Mar i
H4 plusour
G4 fait
nul et
ok la dernière partie avec 5+ 1 SAF sauf
s'il y avait grosse racelé mais si on
atteint si on a une partie serrée comme
d'habitude les 9 RA pourux qui ont
par tu vois si vous aviez
écouté Kevin vous SZ pas bien là pas du
tout pas du tout ils se disent malin
malin ça va fonctionner et Harik rejoue
euh cette ouverture alors avec H3 c'est
un petit peu différent mais euh c'est
pas c'est pas
foufou pas conquérir le public avec ce
début-là alors qu'avec les noir elle est
très ambitieuse avec les Blancs c'est ce
petit début un peu
triste c'est quel événement c'est le
speed chest
wom champion c'est en
ha très richement doté d'ailleurs pour
les meilleures joueuses
internationales du coup elles sont
vraiment très très
présentes on a toutes les meilleures
joueuses
quasiment avec la numéro 1 mondiale qui
s'est qualifiier
an au dépend d'Alexandra kenuk qui a été
champion du monde vainqueur de d'une
édition aussi de
speedchess du
coup lagno est clairement favorite comme
je le disais maintenant on voit que
harika qui nous faisait une très belle
impression dans les différents matchs
qu'on a pu commenter on parle pas que du
speedchess des autres compétitions
chasscom ben franchement là encore ça
joue bien et avec une ligne un peu plus
confidentielle on voit qu'elle a réussi
a a gêné beaucoup plus qu'elle ne
l'avait fait dans les autres parties
Katarina lagno qui a une sorte de paté
de pièce là ouais commence à être un peu
désagréable histoire il y a un problème
sur pion des5 et aussi sur le pion sur
le fou le 6 parce que si tu prends le6
des problèmes plus tard sur le sur les
cas blanches avec l'absence du du f cas
blanche des noirs on voit qu'elle est
moins contente Catharina lagno là ouais
pu elle fait un CP tête tout à l'heure
genre en en elle a fait un coup de tête
ouais c'est pas pas c'est pas
foufou elle va vraisemblablement se se
retrouver moins bien autant parce
qu'elle est sous pression déjà s faut
pas que revient ouais mais elle savait
pas trop quoi jouer et là est-ce qu'on
pique la paire de fou on joue ces tris
tours1 on travaille sur le pion e stouf
ouais j'ai envie aprs j'aime bien c tour
ouais tu maintiens le pressing ouais
parce que sur un cou comme d dame de
aussi comme ça h C4 quand Mme mais
oui il faut faut juste faire gaffe à ça
C4 vis-à-vis très bien joué le jeu de
couleur moi j'aime beaucoup ce coupl
Stouff avec l'idé cavalier prend
E6 une fois que les cases blanche sont
ouvertes voilà maintenant cavali l'air
plus ouais c'est super a hyper bien joué
bravo
areka beaucoup plus précis que ce que
j'ai indiqué avec cavalier prend E6 elle
a fait C4 d'abord grosse pression
forçant l' a réagir et là elle fait une
grosse partie Harik avec son début
confidentiel et encore plus confidentiel
avec H3 parce que c'est une ligne un peu
plus marginale bah ça m'a beaucoup plus
plu il y avait une petite idée et elle a
réussi à mettre un pressing en place et
là
comment je en grande difficultéend comme
ça j'ai au moins quo ouais ro F7 alors
ça me plaît pasess de de faire
le un truc comme ça je
G3 pour jeer pour F4 et puis bah ramener
les pièces en jeu quoi ah tu vas tu vas
me faire mal hein là on sent
que tu peux me faire très très mal F F4
ça peut être F F5 derrière si je fais
rien faut pas que ça déconne parce que
ouais ça peut vite ça donne le pion
direct elle ve des compensations
peutêtre sur la sur la colonne
ouverte elle a pas pris
directement tout cas pas pass
pour leur dernière partie
vraisemblablement sur ce format là
attention si continue elle pourrait
prendre de point d'avance alors tu vois
un peu ce qu'elle a fait parce que là
défend le pion 5 donc finalement a pas
voulu manger mais elle ve en fait elle
veut les cases blancheselle aur pu
manger ici par tu aussi dans l'idée
vraiment elle joue sur les cas blanches
et elle prend pas le
matériel c'est aussi de pressing tout à
fait j'ai 6 d 6
ro bouge et euh non j'ai pas TR prend
le5 là faut qu'on fasse gaffe quand même
quand on joue dame E6 la dame elle est
un peu bizarre ouais faut pas qu'elle
soit enfermée quand même ça je suis
capable de la faire enfermer mais to la
totale et même ça peut être un
enfermement d'échange entre guillemets
pour échanger ta dame h et mais bon j'ai
pas de dame E7 comme j'aimerais tu vois
il aur tout prend E5 ou dame 7 5 ouis
c'est pas simple de de réussir parce que
j'ai toujours des trucs ça donne
toujours pas envie ouais mon tour truc t
8 j'ai le droit
peut-être t je pe je crois que je dois
faire ça dame
prend dame D7 peut-être ouais bon prise
prise tour ok c'est quand même quand
même encore des trucs hein ouais ça
commencer pas grandchose tour 7 il y
aurait peut-être pas grandchose hein
tout
simplement là si elle peut jouer tour8
sans perdre elle va le jouer hein ouais
dame7 encore correct avec non elle a pas
tour8 derrière à cause de fou prend F6 a
AE AE sur ça je peux pas jouer ça à
cause de ça oh si elle pouvait
jouer si elle ça marchait de de jouer
euh
ouais elle a
pas la menace avec les avec les Blancs
quand même je sais pas mais on est bien
coincé avec les Noirs j'ai une belle
position mais c'est quoi la menace ouais
c'est pas facile de
travailler estce que je je vois pas
comment je continue j'ai pas tout
regardez les F4 mais je n'arrive pas à
les valoriser avec
pareil non faut travailler ce que je
peux jouer comme H4 avec idé c'est la
partie l'idée c'est un jour peut-être de
faire damage 3 je pensais il y a pas eu
de ressortir sur case
blanche mais bon il y aura TR inéressant
j'ai dit le stouf
ouais pas mal pas mal mais que c'est
bien ça c'est autre chose ça c'est autre
chose mais l'idée c'est que je voulais
ESS de faire ça mais que j'avais mal
avec non mais la position était pas
facile à convertir et maintenant je
trouve qu'elle laisse du contrejeu
presque c'est ça qui est terrible bah
c'est ça ouais deux tours sont installés
cavalier
F4 débutang j'ai le pion au début oui
oui elle elle a voulu vous avez vu à ce
niveau-là des fois on prend pas le
matériel pour parce qu'il y avait
plusieurs types d'avantages elle a
préféré l'avantage d'activité des pièces
et finalement elle a pas réussi à le
valoriser donc elle aurait dû encaisser
le pon dame F7 attention he il y a ou et
j'ai encore G6 en l' donc tu peux pas
trop trop manger C4 F6 al Ian je pense
que les tour online elle a toujours un
petit elle a toujours bien aimé après
elle a pas annoncé un grand
comeb il y avait une idée rigolote trou
c'était dame C4 hg6 et H6 parce que ça
valait j'ai beaucoup de mal à évalueris
tuas pas trop de jouer en prtique Gumble
style et redamage 3 peut-être qui me
rentre sur les cases blanches aïe ouais
damage 3 ça fait mal donc on bon faut
garder le roi en S en sécurité beaucoup
plus normale ce qui a été fait attention
retourner a elle a joué très passif G4
c'est une menace
hein ro G1 comment j'arrive à passer ce
fou P ouvrir le le fou c'est quand même
très content tour ouis mais tour c'est
bien
travailler ici inversé T5 peut-être
est-ce qu'on fait pas un petit fou C7
histoire de j'aime bien fou C7 pour
avoir la perspective FO 5 dans certains
cas discret est-ce que même passer comme
ça c'est si bête ah c'est bien c'est
long mais mais tu jou pasar
bien du coup si tu me fais un petit truc
St comme ça j'essaie de jouer fou D3
pour t'embêter sur E5 ouais c'est V que
je peux pas tout faire quand
même tout faire mais si je peux mettre
mon fou ici en un
coup déjà en F4 en c'est pas mal pas mal
heureux
quoi alors là on a une belle position
mais il faut encore terminer hein je
crois que ça marche pas H4
oui Alb oui oui demifinale ici c'est
c'est clair que que tu gagnes déjà un
beau petit pctol après je sais pas sont
ah les prix sont indiqués hein je peux
les donner si veux Stouff mais ouais
vraimentou c'est vraiment très important
honêement quand je regardais la dernière
fois
ce j'ai dit que j'allais les trouver
mais bon c'est bien que ça ah ça y est
oui
final et c'est 10000 € pour pour 10000
dollars pardon pour la gagnante plus
10000 dollars selon le pourcentage de
victoire et quand tu fais demi-finale
c'est 6000 dollars plus 6000 dollars
selon le nombre de victoire donc il y a
vraiment ok bon c'est quand même bien
payé ouais ouais ou ou oui c'est on
comprend qu'il y a du monde par que
c'est pas non plus trop trop long quoi
il y a pas des3 là Stouff ou là là F H4
c'est beau aussi ouais ça me donne envie
de rentrer dans la position attention
quand même à D de pouvoir quasiment il a
dame D7 peut-être
F7 Mo j'aime bien ti D3 D3 c'est la
partie dame D7 et dame prend D3 la gaffe
Kevin e benah ouais ça va l'air bien
dame prend TR et oui c'est ça que je
voulais rouler comme Catarina je disais
Catarina tactiquement elle était pas au
mieux forme aïe aïe
aïe bon mais c'est pas sûr que alle
c'est pas sûr que Harik gagne elle est
elle est vraiment oh là là elle donne
les pions
là qu'est-ce qui se passe là est-ce
qu'il y a un le temps 20 secondes 30
secondes ça peut être n'importe quoi TR
c'est possible j'ai l'impression que tu
vas mat tu vas mat avec avec les Blancs
he là là c'est c'est très très en prise
alors je n'importe quoi que je suis en
prise ouais non mais ça peut vite Viller
cette pause on s les blancs sont gagnant
dame F8 dame F8 ah bah c'est ce que le
coup que je voulais jouer stouf comme
quoi on a les mêmes idées mais c'est
pas fou j'ai TR attention
hein 3 put raté oh là là là là là on
sait pas
quoi tour 6 tour 6 ça gag en un coup
quoi gag en un coup ah ouais mais tu
vois la PR temps la pression du
temps ok la
pause grosse
pression incroyable oui oui oui Kin
pendant la pause tu veux je varouver
cette partie très très vite ouais moment
il y a il y a notre petit nal qui qui
l'a demandé déjà il avait envie de l'
voir tu parles de la partie que j'avais
joué ouais attends
sur trop longtemps et quand j'
ben je vais je vais vous la montrer en 2
secondes
la c'était assez incroyable
année tu vas compléter mon pack sur la
grivacee je vais dire si citrect
thoriquement normalement déjà
bizarrement faut pas jouer 3 attaque la
dame comme on a envie de faire en
premier faut jouer fou D3 avant fou E3 P
c'est ce que j'avais fait je crois mais
mais sans savoir alors atts ah B tu as
été inspiré parce que je trouve ça très
tentant de de faire fou E3 avant pour
attaquer la dame en quelle année en tout
cas on a vu un final assez épique ça
promet en 3+
1 parce qu'il eu
des
des choses assez
fragiles je pense que a pris nul aussi
parce que le contexte a senti qu'elle
avait
complètement craqué en premier
voyant qu'elle éétait remise à
niveau on a la partie contre Christopher
Debray recherche que
truc ah céit lui
làs ce nom HS Palice
ouais alors attends du coup là je peux
pas la mettre je crois la mettre dans
une ouis tu es obligé de mettre une
salle de classe t'inquiè pas je une
analyse mes trucs là
tout
chatespère que tu vas pas réfuter ma
grivace sinon mon pack je peux le jeter
à la poubelle aucune chance hein aucune
chance hein ce serait terrible analyse
euh c'est là ouais c'est ça exact
parfait je crois que chck il va pas être
bon si il est bon il check h c'est vrai
je vais incroyable ouais bon je vous
laisse à côté on s'en fou hein je monte
rapidement d'accord c'est pas ou ou bien
sûr bien sûr bien sûr c'est une partie
que j'ai joué il y a très
longtemps et tu as joué fou D3 he malin
ouis mais je connaissais pas normal je
suis bon c'est ce qu'il veut donc je le
fer plus tard 3 donc moi je préfère A6
jeever il il a joué il a joué D6 un
petit peu trop tôt mais bon ok c'est du
détail3
ou ou c'est normal c'est normal de jouer
comme ça ah oui tuas fait petit Rocket
G4 ou connais pas mais conseillé c'est
grand R et G4 et tu avais tout bon tu
avais placé toutes tes pièces
parfaitement stou tu avais fait le
aligner c'est gagné faut aligner tout en
fait c'est facile à retenir avec les
Blancs faut aligner toutes ces pièces tu
sais balancer un gros G4 et toi tu as
aligné toutes tes pièces tu as fait G4
mais c'est rigolo devant le roi on peut
le faire ouais ouais et
ici ici j'ai fait un coup bizarre en
fait je sais que sur
F5 c'est marrant très souvent le coup
c'est mettre un Caval en le 5 et sur F6
F8 et ça c'est une réaction assz normale
et ça paraît bizarre chez les Noirs mais
au final bah g voilà et du coup je me
suis tiens aujourd'hui je suis inspiré
et j'ai d je fa E5 la SMAT il fait
G6 oh là là là c'est c'est beau et donc
l'idée c'est que bah je perd le pion5
mais dans celle-là j'avais une idée s
fait h pr j'avis prend F7 là euh avec
cavalier pr là et c'était extrêmement
compqu c'est chaud bien c'est compliqué
bon et du coup il me fait prend donc là
j'ai plus tour7 parce que j'ai cavalier
et j'ai plus F G6 tu G6 mais maintenant
ben écoute je la F6 alors tu vois le
coup le 5 ça m'a libéré des cases quand
même et mon donc bon
il bien et puis bon B écoute j'ai des
menaces F7 maintenant je me dis moi si
mon cavalier vient là ou là je suis
quand même pas mal donc je ramène je
mets mon coup en G7 pour pas qu'il bouge
vraim pas que je F3 tu vois il a compris
l'idée dame 3 pour chasser un peu les
cavaliers il est revenu ici je vais F et
maintenant écoute si je fais ça mon plom
c'était de faire H 6 plus Caval F3 pour
caval5 ouais pu tu peux craquer aussi
sur H7 si tu as une tour pour faire mat
exactement sur ça et qu'après je fais C
si le cavalier prend par exemple je fais
coup juste pour vous montrer ben là je
ça et F7 et sil prend magnifique je
menace mat voilà on connaî matches.com
un
peu donc je fais ça et là je prends
parce que sinon il va manger mon fou7 et
maintenant bah j'arrive quoi il me fait
ça
je fais ça et là ici on a
second
je
mais bon tu lae tu dis mais c'est
quo c'est bien B
bordel
magifp j'ai tu peux prendre G4 quand
même cause de ah ou
d'ver et là j'ai mangé madame et j'avais
vu que sil prend là j'avais échec F7 F8
ou
F7 coup je dis là il fait il fa je dis
mer j'ai ça marche pas et c'est la même
chose tu
voisp
il pas vu et du coup je
réfléch prévu sur C5 et ça perd ça perd
parce qu'en fait après ça bah éche for
plus de
for et en fait le problème c'est que là
il a G3 je complètement oublié G3 ah oui
oui ça c'est vraiment les quoi j'ai
essayé he et ah oui il av une promotion
cavalieris mais tu es toujours coincé il
est H8 et en pourquoi je suis gagnant
parce qu'en fait si je fais RO2 ah c'est
dommage euh s'il prend ben j'ai ça en
fait et c'est fini
et c'est c'est fini genre ça ça et je
crois que j'avais vu leur échac pour FK
je crois que il faut pas allerage 2 je
menace mat imparable et sur un beut F
des5 je pense que je fais ça t t t res
voilà j'ai trop de pièce pour la dame en
fait par tu vois mais bon ok moi j'étais
moi j'étais inspiré je
pense c une partie que j'ai joué il y a
plus de 10 ans hein mais voilà tu
parlais de ton ton petit truc ça m'a la
grivace là la grivacee mais du coup moi
ce que j'a bien ça donne des parties
folle tu vois c'est vraiment typique ce
que tu as fait des siciliennes
classiques tu sais on balance et les
Noirs réagissent c'est hyper chaud c'est
rigolo ça Mo enfin ça je je jouer tout
le temps sans rien connaître mais
qu'est-ce que je fais ben je je balance
les pions je balance les pièces et puis
j'attaque quoi et puis je sais pas quoi
faire mais tu tu envois ça repris c'est
un repris hein ouais ça arrive inst
instantanment
jouer j'ai pas mis à jour les points
mauvais élèv en tout cas voilà la partie
marrante ou 4 par le mec qui me dit
qu'estce tu V analisé tu as fait
n'importe quoi ouais c'est abusé
franchement j'ai créé des choses tu vois
j'ai perdu ou ou oui oui oui non mais
c'est pas objectif mais j'étais content
de ma partie quoi j'étais content et
j'tais quand même et même si tu avais
fait n'importe quoi bon le mec était pas
obligé de réagir comme ça bon fa
n'importe quoi im si je veux faire
n'importe quoi je fais n'importe quoi
non tu as envoyé tout sur une Sicilienne
bon ben c'est logique
ahch bon c'est dommage prouvé pas mal de
choses dans le 45 ouais ça change un pe
peu peut-re qu'elle peut-être qu'elle
voulait faire on sa pas je pense pas vu
comment elle débite elle a pas l'air
trop surprise c'est vrai que maintenant
on voit cavalier G6 comme ligne alors
qu'avant on mettait tous le cavalier en
F5 c'est logique mon micro est faible
mais je sais pas il est devant moi en
fait mon micro je sais pas quoi faire de
plus euh juste Yume attends je vais
envoyer une photo à Yume parce que Yume
c'est c'est
c'est parce qu'en fait j'ai j'ai plein
de trucs derrière je sais pas trop ce
faire peut-être que je sais pas le bon
mode
euh je t'envoie çaum tu me dis si c'est
bien il est
oùum j'ai plein de mod mais je comprends
pas je sa jamais lequel il faut mettre à
3 B4 quand le centre est bloqué hein
vous prenez l'espace sur les ailes voilà
ce que veut dire cette position donc G3
H4 pour les blancs A3 B4 pour les blancs
voilà les idées
basiques
sur suis à fond
micro truc voz l' cal G6 dans française
d'avance pass par
F6 surège la qui est la
faiblesse maintenant est travaillé par
les Noirs le défaut c'est le petit P
c'est structure thématique de
française6 qui serait maintenant aussi
bien en F5 mais ça aurait été une partie
encore
différente parce que moi je suis en
compour de regarder mais je sais pas
estce que il est mon truc de
micro là j'ai peut-être free
aussi alors fa voir il bien un
truc
yum il bien un
truc et cavalier E7 on voit le cavalier
revenir en en
F5 alors j'ai fait un truc là est-ce que
tu m'entends mieux toi tu m'entends pas
plus mais moi non jeentends toujours
pareil est-ce que sur le chat ça va
mieux là je faire un truc que Yume vient
de me dire est-ce que ça va mieux ou pas
ou est-ce que c'est toujours pas
assez alors dame
D2 pour pour la case de 5 hein souvent
dans cette position SR cavalier F5 a été
joué on est repassé par là on peut faire
prise prise et FO F4 pour la travailler
la case 5 comme tu nous dis stouf sera
assez logique alors attends je encore
augmenter un tout petit peu plus
beaucoup mal inspiré en fait elle a pas
su trop quoi jouer elle est pas sans
doute familière à de cette position et
si a joué très correctement le début
après au niveau des plans des fois quand
on connait pas les positions c'est plus
dur de se mettre en marche
ouais là c'est bon j'ai encore mis micro
apparemment c'est bon là ce que vous me
dites est-ce que Yume tu tu confirmes
que c'est c'est ok là je suis plus
donc là la position est vraiment
meilleure à la base pour les blanc qui
fait travailler tranquillement la case
en E5 le coup F5 qui bloque le fou D7
attention est- de la tactique ici
découverte comme ouis je
regardais mais je défends mon fou exact
par que sinon ça aurait pu être pas mal
de manger intermédiaire ici pour
récupérer
aprs je déend Mon' fou ouais al
peut-être cavalier
A5 la ah non peut pas là bon dis-moi tu
vas être bien pour ton tournoi toi tu
pars quand
déjà petite gaffe par jeudi je crois
d'ailleurs ouais je pars jeudi matin je
pars jeudi matin et demain demain il y a
finale aussi hein stouf euh donc finale
à 13h hein demain 1 la finale ouais
entre la gagnante de ce match là et
fan 750
750 alors dame 7 moi j'aime beaucoup les
blancs quand
même un ptit F3 changer quelques petites
pièces c'est un petit peu plus facile
comme ça attention
ouais puis G5 aussi faut pas oublier le
discret
G5 é joué mais moi j'avais peur de ça ça
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui se passe elle
croque bah ouais hein en plus tu es mal
au temps donc quand tu es mal autant tu
as intérêt à à prendre des décisions
rapidement mais tu es un peu en mode
quoi F G5 c'était pas mal pour essayer
d'enlever le F est-ce que prend tu ou
pas je regarderis plutôt tu reprend plus
naturel mais pion prend c'est très
intéressant parce que tu as un P de moin
donc là c'estoser bien bien sûr donc tu
ça favorise l'attaque mais ce fou ici
fait pas grandchose peut-être le mettre
en le mettre en8 c'est vraiment énervant
ouais j'aime bien pu on prend essayer de
créer des choses mais je comprends que
pu on prend ça offre des qu aussi pour
activer le fou noir
donc dites-moi dans le chat s'il vous
plaît par rapport à à mon micro est-ce
que c'est est-ce que c'est bien est-ce
que vous m'entendez bien ou est-ce qu'il
faut ajouter encore un petit peu de bon
ça c'est bien joué D 7 donc dans F4
probablement H4 un peu mieux pour les
noirs avec le P plus mais c'est actif
hein côté blanc donc c'est casse gueule
un jeu de couleur hein
clairement mais euh il y a un P de plus
pour les pour les Noirs mais c'est que
les Blancs senflamme pas elle joue
presque pour nul ouais elle trouve la
position cassegeule je pense d'ailleurs
lagno continue hein cette position il va
essayer de quelque chose sur le roi dame
B4 là quandême dame B4 sans doute ah
c'est pas mal
aussi elleut s'activer à tout prix ouais
mais elle s'est pas beaucoup
activécoup c'est beaucoup mieux merci
beaucoup
ok c'est bien appar
voilà presque G7 ça
March dame éche dame
d Mang à la
fin
P plus mais chance de N fa nul cette
position j'ai pas le temps de
voir ça
gagné en fait c'est pas
clair TER plus dommage j'ava BR une
bonne idé mais
ok ok maintenant nul à cause du pion F3
qui est en l'air
ouis ça va faire nul oh bah attention
quand même il faut pas non c'est
oublier c'est plus que
nul faut juste faire gaffe autant de pas
oublier
ouais là faut bouger le fou et
attendre
ouais elle est
nulle suivante
ah d'ailleurs j'ai pas corrigé les les
la
prédiction tout à l'heure du premier set
on va corriger de suite et et on va
lancer une autre prédiction pour
pour pour le le deè set al
prédiction alors en plus avait 95%
pourik quand même
incroyable
hein elle varie hein c'est Yume qui
avait qui avait mis Hine sur Surik
ouais équilibré encore donc là on a le
droit une un début
jobava système moderne on attaque pas
mal des fois dans ces variantes on peut
faire la marée de pion avec F3 G4 là
Harik se contente d'un d'un système un
peu plus modeste avec fou des3
dans cette dans cette position qui fait
réfléchir Catarina nagno il y a pas de
problème particulier pour les Noirs
pouvez rester en F5 P prendre P jouer
fou
G6 alors je vous ai mis la petite
prédiction sur
youtube5 c'est vraiment une bêtise par
contre il a kb5 en un coup je crois kb5
K6
ouis c'est3 après mais faut faire gaffe
parce que B5 je peux pas me faire il y a
pas de thème elle aurait dû jouer k B5
pour fixer justement le cavalier A6 stou
si on peut le faire on le
joue k B5 fallait regarder fou prend3
peut-être mais il a K7 intermédiaire
donc k B5 était vraiment
pénible53 à4 et maintenant j'ai tour C8
peut-être ah bah là c'est ouais elle
fait les bonnes choses à cont-temps elle
a raté cavalier B5 elle a regretté de
pas l'avoir joué je
pense
BON4 au moins elle essaie de faire
quelque chose mais attention a 6 elle
est en train
de de s'enfoncer toute seule parce que
K3 il y aura des DPR C4
B5 mais là pas mal pour pour les noir
ici c'est raté un petit peu côté je vous
invite à parier sur sur le score ou
gagnant de ce set si vous voulez VO
Caterina 49000 Arik 10000 et nul 36000
donc des suppor je pense bah pour
l'instant on est il y a eu un match nul
il reste 38 minutes dans ce set tout est
possible he absolument tout est possible
donc vous avez environ encore 3 minutes
pour prendre vos paris bravo elle a
trouvit Catarina vraiment la meilleure
ligne elle a pris un pion central
ouverture complètement ratée
pour Harik ouais ça risque Deon c'est 3+
1 vous voyez donc
forcément ça peut pas être propre tout
le temps h et le match qui est encore
serré on a 54 pourik pour l'instant ce
match et si Catarina venait à gagner
cette partie il aur 55 donc une
égalité al fout6 d' prend D6 tour
D1 attention 4 qui peut arriver donc là
je bougerai la dame
peut-être pas me mettre en
face a une pression là donc génalement
les vis-à-vis c'est important d dès
qu'il y a un vis-à-vis vous partez hein
c'est une règle vous allez vite tout les
tactiques exactement surtout avec
l'avantage d'un pion Catarina elle veut
jouer vite cette position et et garder
son avantage Rock Tour C8 on joue
simple B3 on va reculer la tour alors
pas ici t
C54 la tour très malin et maintenant
tour C8 ouais tour C8 sur
tour d franç c'est pas
Mali c'est pas mal
effectivement c'est plus solide ouais ah
des fois ça va vite donc on fait des
petits petites blagues pour voir si vous
suivez al maintenant ça marche t ça
March c'est maintenant j'ai dam F8 voilà
exact parce qu'il a plus mettre du
couloir et j' r H2 à la fin tranquille
toujours ce pion de plus que Katarina
veut sauvegarder jusqu'à la fin de
partie et valoriser en
finale prise prise à 4 alors plus les
pions sont changer plus il y a chance de
nul dans cette finale mais à 4 en reste
encore beaucoup hein il en reste encore
beaucoup on dit que les finales de
cavaliers marchent comme les finales de
pion donc avec le gros pion de plus on
gagnerait il n'y a plus que des dames à
échanger pour garantir une finale assez
facile ce qu'elle fait en plus la
Catarina cavalier 5 cavalier C6
cavalier ça m'a l'air
bien plus trop d'idée ici en fait avec
ses pièces en prime ouais d'avoir le
pion de moins et ça tourne6 très bien il
en B4 on voit que ça navque sur les
bonnes cases à tout et merci pour ton
aide pas mal4 pour Esser de jouer plutôt
une finale de dame alors cavalier B4 ça
semblit plus
logique cette finale de dame paraît plus
difficile à à gagner en pratique je sais
pas ce que tu en penses tout j'aurais
pas fait ce choix là ouais pe garder les
cavaliers ça peut être pas mal parce que
a un P plus mais les dames il y a S les
parpétuel ou çapiré d'avance d'essayer
de gagner cette position bon on va voir
toute la
technique de Catarina lagno ENF
espérons-le moi j'ai envie de prendre un
cours de technique là Stouff avecar
il y a quand même l'aspect temps aussi
he qui mais regarde c'est très bien ce
qu'elle a fait non E5 et elle veut vite
se créer un gros pion passé h pas mal
dame C3 alors je peux toujours manger
hein un peu plus haut tu sais h cétait
quand même plus agréable si on
réussissait à ah ok là j' j'ai ah mais
j'ai BA en l'air maintenant ah oui c'est
elle s'est fait un petit peu retourner
là ouais ouais tout à fait euh après je
peux donner des7 jou jouer des TR quand
même hein ouais D3 est-ce que je peux
pas aller de le chercher parce que tu me
paraist fixé joue roi F1 D3 tu veux
jouer ro F1 ouais je sais pas comment tu
V protéger je ne sais pas non plus et
c'est une galère parce que ah non H5 en
plus en un coup j'ai vu après mais ok
ouais donc en fait tu fixé elle a quand
même mangé ai elle a quand même réussi à
trouver un PR 3 hein ouais c'est pas mal
elle reste toujours mieux est-ce qu'on
joue euh dame B2 je jouerais bien pour
essayer de d'embêcher le se ouais mais
il y a le pion B7 et F7 à ouais c'est7
et dame B2 ce que je voulais
mais la majoré nu ça va être dur de de
gagner pour l'instant je prends pas le
cours de technique hein stouf ah le roi
qui va sortir le roi noir va sortir il
faut tenter
ouis d un roi6 dame C6 pas mal pour
essayer de d F3 peut-être de gêner la
défense il faut essayer de de tenter
hein de gagner cette position atttion
plus
10attendu pour remettre la dame en D5
peut-être al il faut jouer ro F6
peut-être ouais fa faudra tenter à un
moment là la sortie sortir je sais pas
comment mais j'aimais bien la de sortir
le roi mais avec la dame en D5 peut-être
pas hein ouais pour ou ça y est ça y est
on a la position que je voulais tout à
l'heure j'estimais que c'était assez max
de faire cela
ok B a changé le dispositif ouais qu
même vachement embêté làarrive pas à
sortir là c'est là c'est perpè je crois
des deux côtés
stir voilà ah
ouais ouais un raté là
c'est alors il nous reste à peu près une
demiheure de 3+ 1 on a le temps d'en
voir vraiment c grands maximum 4 ou 5 3+
1 et toujours ce point d'écart stouf
ouais toujours ce petit ce petit point
d'écart et euh pour l'instant c'est un
match qui se déroule un petit peu comme
on a vu oui lors du dernier match entre
ouan costenuk et ouifan où a mené
pendant tout le match et il s'est fait
retourner en bullette alors pour
l'instant bon juste est quand même
devant hein dans les les deux portions
euh bon il a encore une demi-heure de
Blitz hein pas encore
terminé voir un peu comment ça ça va se
dérouler donc tours à l'air logique tour
C dame D2 k G3
ais elle ressigne pour la même chose
elle fait un E5 plus rapide bien réussi
son ouverture cette
fois pe k C4 maintenant attention
hein sur cavalier prend cavalier prend
fou D4 TR du style
ouais il va falloir éteindre cavalier C4
de toute façon
ouais ça c'est trop trop compliqué trop
de problème sur le P B2 il faut réussir
à l'changer F4 maintenant ou alors prise
pu F D4 donc les Noirs ont trouvé de
l'activité mais au prix d'un pion isolé
faible sur le long terme et les blancs
doivent éteindre l'activité noire tout
simplement est-ce qu' cou comme t B3
aussi est possible essayer de faire tour
D1 taper sur B7 et sur sur D5 c'est
logique mais F D4 bon c'est c'est bien
c'éit une de tes propositions pour être
stable ouais fou F7 c'est passif bon
c'est tranquille à jouer en tout cas qu'
on peut jouer cavalier F5 dame
D2 cavalier H5 ah j'aime beaucoup Jol
jolie son dame prend attaque matant G7
qui sera quasiment qui sera même
imparable impossible laarît donc là on
va réussir à piquer la paire de fou au
au noir ah oui KAV H5 c'est très joli
hein et je crois que c'est avantage
écisif hein
k parce que si tu joues pas ça j'ai
cavalier prend puis on prend et tu es
complètement ouvert c'est vraiment le
gros drame cavalierche
ouais c'est pas facile alors qu'avit le
sa défense hein mais on a une grosse
poubelle avec le foot case noire qui est
rayonnant la structure qui est
dramatique donc il a tout qui va
mal très très dur maintenant il faut
juste que
ou ou la position est vraiment
top tu ques la colonne je vais la
prendre moi avec tour C C5 il faut que
tu gardesour ici tour8 ok moi j'aime
bien tour C1 là hm hm dame D2 aussi
c'est toujours un coup euh D2 c'est bien
aussi logique pour travailler sur les
cases noires moi
d normal mais bon il y a une 25 contre
206 AR même si elle a une position
difficile
elle est M temp pour Caterina falloir
accélérer Caval 5 là j'ai mê dans F4 un
jouer simple ok faut F5 est-ce qu' faut
G6
voilà F4 F4 maintenant toujours je garde
mon idée j'aime bien de il faudra
trouver quelque chose à base de tour D1
donc d'abord on va gérer le fou F5 et
après tour
D1 c'est de taper sur le
[Musique]
pion dur pour les Noirs mais ça résiste
et vous savez qu'avec une minute à la
pendule tout peut se
tout peut se
passer B3 a été
jouéente bah disons qu' faut envoyer des
coups et c'est elle sait qu'elle est
beaucoup mieux mais
elle sait pas comment avancer mais B3
j'aime pas du tout parce que j'aime pas
non plus c'tait stable le fou défendait
maintenant si je bouge à 3 l'air et si
je pousse là ben il y a la ce B4 comme
tout à l'heure
ouais assez bizarre mais après j'imagine
qu'elle elle aime pas qu'4 elle a voulu
essayer de c'est pris cavalier F7 ouais
bon dame G4 du coup cavalier H6
attention ou ou Aï aïe aïe ça peut ça
peut vite briller vous voy
dame dame prend c'est au pire des cas
ouais dame prend dame au pire ou tu peux
faire prise prise
F3 dame prend dame suivi de fou E6 fou
F7 et puis on échange
oui c'est mieux on rétablis pas la
structureè préfère C parce que si je
prends là tu rétabli la structure donc
c'est mieux de faire F 6 comme tu comme
tu on va rapprocher un peu le roi mais
bon préconise
ouais là tu me laes de manger là quand
même hein c'est un gros problème 6 fou
F7 prend roi prend prise ah il a fou D7
même et sur tour
D8 si tu veux peut-être juste fou bouge
quoi Foug non c'est pas mal de garder
j'aime bien ce qu'elle a fait encore une
fois waouh tour7 c'est grande classe
ouais faire attention la tour quand même
c'est vachement bien joué fou D7 avec le
C contrôle ouais c'est clair j'ai bien
aimé elle a fait une super séquence avec
seulement 40
secondesche 6 Provo F est- qu'on peut
croer ou pas ça croque ou pas pr défend
ça Dom
oublié qu'elle l'a vu mais qu'elle
voulait pas prendre de risque B
là F5 a a a bah c'est elle qui se l'a
fait coller a a ah ça fait mal ça
c'était le risque avec 20 secondes à la
pendule maintenant elle va jouer pour
nul mais- peore ça ça ça peut-être mais
bon il à la fin il y aura tour il y aura
même roi F7
ouais peut faire mal bonelle préfère
donner le fou c'est bien joué ah non il
y a cavalier F5
encore tu reprends B6 maintenant
cavalier F5 aïe aïe AE aïe aïe là on est
parti dans Ah ouais
calier encore mieux et on envoie des
cartes
pous quand
même
P surpriseend
S
faitetourner elle vair qu dommage
ça joue
bien
allez F6 le cavalier qui va partir par
où
is c'est encore ne des questions y a
tour F2 qui
menace vou jouer attention prend de et
maintenant c'est presque nul cette
positionme des pion enc si j'arrive à
échanger c'est pas facile du
tout ça se retourne voyez vitesse grandv
alorson
enter Catarina c'est toujours la
pression celui qui a le gros avantage
l'autre joue lâch cou et joue bien on a
vu que Catarina quand elle était en
difficulté elle lâch ses coup elle arriv
quand même à faire mal
attention soit pas le drame regardez le
plan AR mais
manger i là bien joué
attention6 voilà I ah j'aurais bien joué
tour F6
d'abord GAE C atttion
fourchette attention je venir ici la col
attention une seconde temp horrible trop
dur attention il faut jouer des
coups c'est
Chud
attention G6 peut-être à un moment r H3
elle est venu en G3 ou il y Ava éch t
point F4 elle a rrêé T voyez vous voyez
les il y a toujours en plus ouis mais
bon il y a F8 t F8 elle a trouvé
incroyable mant c'est nul mal maintenant
on joue pour gagner
ou elle joue pour gagner en plus tu vois
elle aurait pu faire tour prend à 5 t pr
F4 est nul incroyable incroyable
retournement il a eu double retournement
là incroyable bon vous voyez hein ce que
c'est euh je sais pas quoi penser après
un zot pingpong comme ça ça promet pour
le le Bullet on voit que les les deux
jeunes femmes jouent très bien mais il y
a forcé moment des moments de flottement
avec aussi pe de temps la prend c'est du
blit c'est c'est c'est dur de tout gérer
hein mais quand même Catarina lagno
avait fait une super partie je trouvais
très technique he stouf et puis un
moment elle se prend la peau de banale
de la fourchette alors qu'elle avait
tout maîtrisé elle est passée dans un
mode un peu plus arnaque pour bah se
refaire elle a réussi et ça a failli
faire craquer harika qui avait quand
même bien défendu dans un premier temps
mais avoir l'avantage dans ce type de
cadence et de vouloir contrôler c'est
extrêmement difficile un Stouff hm hm
yes une seconde on m'appelle pourquoi on
[Musique]
m'appelle une pe seconde hein je t'en
prie je t'en prie je t'en prie je t'en
prie bon on est parti
pour pour quelque chose d'assez
positionnel
avec une un système est inden proposé
par les Noirs donc G3 fou G2 tranquillou
le système assez assez simple et caratar
lagno qui avait pris l'espace avec B5
c'était plutôt une bonne idée et là vous
l'avez vu elle a joué un C5 un peu
douteux et s'est fait enfermer le fou B7
avec D5 les blancs on maintenant plus
d'espace et le fou B7 est hyper mal
placé les blancs joueront un moment pour
45 dans ce type de
position que l' dame c'est plutôt le
côté
noir peut-être H3 avec les Blancs pour
faire45 pour éviter cavalier G4 un
moment position pour les blancs de manre
générale je trouve que c'est est-ce
qu'on fait cavalier C4 j'aime pas j'aime
bien c C4 bien cavalier prend aussi
avec tu as du mal à garderre
B5 k dame B5 A4 non parce que là on est
proche de l'enfermement de dame ouais je
crois que tu vas d'ailleurs me l' manger
TR éche et mat à la dame voilà c'est ce
que vous avez vu le petit triuc parce
que dame B5 ça donne envie mais en fait
on va jouer dame C7 ouais si j'ai le
temps de faire un truc mais non dame C7
de 4 voilà ouais ouais là c'est B6
changer quelques pièces B6 est-ce que
alors il faut toujours regarder cavalier
A5 mais je peux perdre du matos des fois
avec des mais qu' B6 à 5 peut-être aussi
5 qui est embêtant oui eu 5 tu as raison
tu as raison c'était notre idée en plus
est-ce que je fais à 4 F C3 ou dir 6 ça
c'est thématique pour aller manger
peut-re jouer F3 au coup d'avant tu vois
mais bon il a toujours FO 6
façonutêre jouer F C3 quand
même contrôle les cases ou H3 toujours
H3 dans ses positions pour éviter
G45 mais a cavalier B6 maintenant qui
est présent donc fou C3 lavite cavalier
B6 mais cavalier G4 peut-être voilà et
on n pas eu le timing tu elle a pas
réussi à ouais je suis cloué hein ah
j'avais pas vu ce petit euh ce petit
dame C3 pourtant si je suis cloué jeux
pas ça fonctionne pas je peux pas manger
malheureusement parce qu'à la fin à
chaque fois puis a tour B4 maintenant
toutoufin qui va
euh gérer le problème h je pense que les
Noirs est-ce qu'on fait cavalier E5 on
peut faire C5 peut-être Souf he a Aï a K
F6 c'est pas la case naturelle et C je
te donnais peut-être la qualité
avec6 si tu vois la pause mais si si si
si si
ok mais bon c'est après 5 c'est c'est
pas sûr quand même avec le K6 des
foisemmène comme ça les fameux cavaliers
sur la 6e et tu sais ils se font un peu
chahuter avec le 6 mais bon c'est dur
d'évaluer ouais TR très dur en tout cas
le 5 c'est hyper thématique et attention
il a quand même des pions en l'air c'est
ça donc là c'est c'est un peu le double
tranchant et il Arik qui joue quand même
hyper actif mtenant elle elle a raison
et il faut qu'elle joue qu'elle joue de
manière active parce que elle commence à
se faire un peu retourner avec tour B8
et le problème sur C4 sur A4 sur B3 et
il faut jouer des coups un
peu c'est vraiment marrant tac tac parce
que Dame des de Dam attention hein
dangereux
ouais est-ce que pr c 4 coup moi je te
mange oui évidemment alors j'ai mon Cavé
en l' quand même je peux pas tout manger
B6 bon est-ce que là je tente ah je
voulais tenter d'AM 6 alors le 6 du coup
j' toujours6 hein
ouis il y av les idées à base de kg5
ouais très
intéressant et sur ça tu veux jouer5 B
il y aura il y aura ce type de TH ouais
ça sera super intéressant c'est embêant
tu le 5 qui a été joué ça ça m'a l'air
bizarre tout est bizarre ici ça m'a
l'air suspect ce petit coup de cavalier
pe peut-être faire cavalier E5 et prise
F7 pour les cases blanches s'il y a pas
mieux on joue ça mais c'est très
compliqué comme position avec une
structure atypique des pions en l'air
chez les Blancs un roi en l'air chez les
Noirs prise cavali préféré faire prise
F7
ok après cavalier prend F7 on a l'air de
de se faire un peu éteindre ça je
préféis cavalier prend5 moi aussi je
trouvais que la structure était
le 5 va tomber maintenant non s'est
trompé elle avait fait une jolie partie
d'attaque je trouvais et et et là ce
cavalier G5 elle s'est fait ouais
endormir elle a un peu perdu ses moyens
j'ai l'impression dans ce dans cette
partie attention il y a quand même plus
de temps donc on sait que ça peut
vriiller complètement gagnant pour pour
Catarina lagno mais complètement gagnant
en LAN dans ce genre de position le fait
d'avoir un petit truc sur le roi avec H4
h c'est déjà
des des petits rêves B lointain quand
même après ce coup tour F5
qui C4 j'attaque je défends d D5 je
comprends bien mais
bon F bon coupac là t les
dam le problème c'est que la décision il
a 20 secondes contre 40 et ça c'est
complètement indécis parce que la
position est trop trop pas typique pour
pouvoir la gérer face facilement je
prends des pion c bien sûr pas Touvrir
la colonne quandme gentil
mais tour B1 regarde contre je attention
tour
attention très Jol bien joué bien joué
j'avais pas vu je l'AV pas vu non plus
ça c'est joli ça belle manière de
défendre cavalier B2 avec2 et maintenant
je commence àer dame C2
je mais c'est pas clair ro F2 dame C2 ro
F3 et dame D6
ouais j'ai des écheac elle a elle est
parti ici les pièces sont loin il y a du
dame B7 du dame
D6 F5 peut-être juste hein dame F5 juste
dame7
ouais oh là attends c'est qu'est-ce que
c'est que ça ça c'est quoi là cavalier
E3 oh là là oh là là lae il s passé des
choses oh là là elle va elle va c'est en
fait c'est mat ouais ouais ouais là là
on va pas on va pas sur le coin pour se
faire matter cé hyper bizarre
les paniqu un petit
peuimpression avec manque de temps
est-ce que je peux manger ou
pas je je je joue après j'ai
plusinitiative tu peuxarder
é allé dans le mavais coin là sous
pression on l' tous vu
se faire enfermer le RO on a 6 et
demi pour très très dur il y a que des
nul tout à l'heure que des nuls on est à
une 2 3 4 5 6 7 nul d'affilé c'est vrai
7 nul d'affilé c'est quand même
incroyable et pourtant c'est pas des
serrures c'est-à-dire que ça joue quoi
on voit des parties extrêmement
compliquées mais dans le 3+ 1 à cette
cadence hyper rapide il y a eu que des
Nules de combat extrêmement
spectaculairire parce qu'on a vu il y a
eu il a eu pour l'inant on est on est à
12 parties joué et seulement trois
parties décisives ça c'est incroyable
quand tu vois le score et tu me dis que
Catarina a gagné une fois mais elle a
jamais gagné avec les Blancs Catarina
elle a gagné se fois gagné avec blanc
pardon c'est une chansion elle a gagné
avec les Blancs elle a gagné avec les
blancs en plus et c'està dire qu'elle
arrivait pas à faire la la décision avec
les quand quand Harik a les blancs c'est
à chaque fois un match nul depuis le
début du match c'est ça ouais c'est ça
que je voulais dire je me suis un peu
embrouillé Souf et tu l'as bien
remarqué j'ai pas vu le début c'est un
début c'est quoi c une ponani ou c une
alors je peuxire depuis le début si tu
veux ouais je veux
bien donc
espagnol cavalier 7 ah oui cavalier 7
d'ailleurs çaou on on a ce gen de
position
le début
ok ok bon c'est plus facile à jouer pour
les blancs avec la structure il faut
juste problème
ouais faut trouver un moment donné un
moyen de de virerion
aussi bon après est-ce que F3 c'est pas
thématique dans ce genre de positionou
justement faut faire gaffe de pas se
prendre une tactique en un coup mais je
crois qu'on peut le jouer alors j'ai
avantage développement donc ça me paraî
logique d'ouvrir le jeu
rapidement maintenant c'estir de jouer
qu'est-ce que je je joue en fait c'est
pas évident trou un pour les noir parce
que
ouais ça ça même D3 mais là avec
cavalier enfin que là si tu fais G6 en
temps ça vous les G noir aussi G6 il a
le vis-àis a 5 ça va m faire je voulais
faire ça m'aide à prendre une décision
peutêtre que tu peux bloquer comme ça OK
est-ce que je joue C4 et même là j'ai D3
qui est intéressant ou D4 parce que sur
pu on prend j'ai prend ah non excuse-moi
je n'importe quoi j'ai
ouais benah j'ai fait un bon truc tout à
l'heure
mais F3 c'était l'idée de de la position
il est peut-être encore mieux
mais ok c'est c'est quand même normal
avec les pions de l'elle de dégommer le
centre en cas de pion pran on peut jouer
d'AM pran et la finale par exemple
est-ce que pion pran est est possible
possible ou tu prend F3 prend deux
points d'interrogation moi je pens son
idée elle areé un truc voir
ou dame F2 al ça c'est ouais d'accord
c'était quand même trop dur ah ouais non
faut faire attention voyait avec les
deux points d'interrogation on avait pas
du tout vu dame F2 je pensais qu' dame
pr F3 avec le petit plus et c'est un
petit plus dame prend F3 c'est le coup
normal de la position dame F2 c'est pour
l'élite de l'élite en partie
lente position était atypique cont oh là
là par contre c'est un gros craquage un
coupec
ouais et on voit P un peu à craquer dans
c parti parment je trouve que ouais
elle est très calme l'no ouais allez si
c'est égalisation mais tu sais il y a un
peu de fatigue hein dans ce genre de bah
oui c'est clair il y a beaucoup de
tension aussi hein ouais c'est ça puis
il y a des grosses aotes on l'a vu
ka elle a
fait un petit plaisir a
ça je conis un petit peu ah
ok ça pour
F qui joue ça avec les noir de temps en
temps ah ouais début ouais un peu à
l'arrache sur avec c'est quand même
bizarre mais quand tu C4 c'est quand
même on va sûrement prendre le C D4
ouais cavalier pr voilà thématique
faut pas échanger les pièces mais après
on peut enlever le4 dans cette position
là B on
verra si je l'enlève je sais pas trop où
a tellement de sché possible pour les
blancs B3 tu peux jouer avec F4 tu peux
jouer pour F F3 H3 en tout cas les Noirs
vont vite faire FO F8 normalement F F8
ça c'est c'est assez thématique ce truc
là menace sur 4 travaille sur F8 c'est
quoi le coup blanc F8 euh faut que je
défend le P 4 je crois que FO F3 il y a
cavalier E5 enfin tu vois c'est c'est
déjà un petit peu embêtant c'est bizarre
qu'elle ait pas joué à tempo donc je
dois
ouais je sais pas F F8 pour moi elle
devrait le jouer vite ouais voilà elle a
elle a mis du temps si tu veux c'est un
coup qu'on peut faire pour mettre la
pression et et c'est au blanc de prendre
la décision je pense pas que F les 5
soit un coup hein je pense que H6 H6
voilà et F3 on a D5 fou D3 elle joue fou
D3 cavalier 5
tempo et on égalisé
hein avec les menaces k G4 les menaces k
prend D3 Souf je suis plutôt content il
y a peut-être d'autres coupér j'aime
bienk tu as tout à fait raison c'est
peut-être encore mieuxaime bien ça parce
si f Bou prends là et tu vas t'emparer
de de ce bon fou là sur cavalier prend
C6 bon on peut calculer cavalier prend3
mais mais bon j'aime pas trop truc même
juste juste al prend non il a prali non
mais cavalier prend3 c'est pas mal non
là l'air bien mais cavalier pr
3 si tu calcules et que tu vois que ça
suffit tu tu manges la mien madame je
mange la tienne bon je tu calcules le3
le pion B2 c'est le mieux mais bon après
en blitz rentrer dans toutes ces
complications là regard c'est la partie
c'est plus facile ouais c'est plus
facile mais parti l tu as le temps de
tout calculer mais là bon tu es pas à
l'abri de d'avoir fait une erreur de
calcul donc c'est c'est pour ça que il
faut quand même mais c'est des positions
qu'elles ont déjà vu toutes les deux
hein ça on peut le dire enfin ce genre
de super
je mange tu mes je m tu
manges Mo j'a
bien pas mal de central
avec rentrer en
jeu4 ai
exister alors C4 Atta
làhaut qui peut jable5 prise
avec5 contresc sur noir moi je veux
jouer un petit G6 fou G7 ouais très très
tenir mon
P je veux jouer tranquille avec le fou
qui tape sur le long terme mon avantage
distinctif c'est le
fou6 fou
B3 j'ai tellement envie de jouer G6 F G7
tour B8 la partie PLA on travaille juste
sur B2 maintenant toute la partie
pendant très longtemps pendant une
séquence de cette partie et du coup ça a
fait réfléchir les blancs et pour les
Noirs c'est très Mécque je mettrai m
dame sur case noire à un moment dame G5
dame E5 dame C5 je sais pas sur la 5e
rangée en tout cas pour voilà mettre la
pression et la tour en B8 en plus ça va
être
génial et c'est surtout beaucoup plus
facile à jouer donc faut jouer vite
voilà 5 j'aime bien c'est dans l'esprit
tour B8 j'aime
bien c'est presque un peu dommage de
laisser le K3 par par ti ouais B3 quoi
tu mangerais toi non non non on pourra
pas on pourra pas mais je voulais
justement intensifier la pression sur B2
elle a trouvé tour B1 B3 mais après c
position ça asse égal hein ça va être
dur de gagner mais je préfère quand même
les noirs avec le
cou c'est une super pièce c'est la
meilleure pièce de la position plus
facile peut-être un petit peu à jouer de
côté noir oui parce que tu as bah c'est
toi qui qui a les cases en fait alors
que le cavalier pas stable le P 4 c'est
la seule faiblesse des blancs mais on va
avoir le droit d'ame G5 le coup tout à
l'heure tu sais avec voilà la dame qui
va j'ai pas aimé 4 sou tu as le cavalier
à 4 tu peux jou et on peut jouer
vraiment vite alors qu'avec les blancs
faut se poser des questions à chaque
fois ouis pu il a des rupur à chaque
fois aussi oui tout à faitveiller un peu
32 moi je jouerisand Mme cas blanche
ouais mais 30 secondes c'est pas facile
C
surtout quand tu viens de prendre une
bulle là tu menassaisend C3 he changer
tout etend 4 à la fin il y avait C6
quand même mais mais c'était très
intéressant et là lagno elle est elle
aime bien ce genre de position elle va
peut-être échanger les dames à un moment
si elle n'arrive pas à passer pour
travailler tu sais
euh autour des des cases avec le le
tandem fou et tour fa qu'elle joue assez
vite pour qu'elle garde le Pr D4 C3 F D4
C3 et cétait le drame ouais et le petit
tri j'ai failli le proposer j'ai failli
proposer j'étais à deux doigts Stouff
pour tout te dire de dire ah fou des cat
on va travailler après je me suis merde
il a c'est TR
euh mais tu sais qu'après moi je vais le
dire de toute façon
donc tu te le gardes pour
toi t réuss dam des4 il va faire jouer
dam des4 pour je suis pas sûr qu'on
arrive à progresser avec les Noirs ni
avec les Blancs quand même mais avec les
Blancs enfin avec les Noirs il faut la C
parce que je pense que toujours un petit
peu mieux et en plus tu mieux a temps et
PE poser quelques petits problèmes
dame3 des4 c'est oui c'est c'est les
blancs qui essaient d'échanger les dames
c'est fou
ouais elle essaie de jouer pour D5 à un
moment ça répété ok
ok elle voulait pas faire nécessairement
et des fois elle a peut-être pas fait
exprès de répéter allez 77 il reste elle
était pas contente elle je crois qu'elle
a oublié tu vois parce que j'ai vu sa
tête à à Catarina lagno elle a était un
petit peu déçue que ça
répète donc là ça va être la dernière
partie du set donc pour ceux qui ont qui
ont parié sur normalement sur vos
prédiction pour l'instant c'est avantage
Catarina mais Harik ne pourra pas gagner
ceux qui ont paré sur le GAM d'Aran 77
je pense pour faire une CIX sur vos
points mais après les autres ça se B en
duel
hein et c'est reparti pour le petit
système petit système bizarre mais qui a
bien fonctionné hein marchait bien donc
elle a changé avec la française je sais
pas pourquoi mais ça marchait bien quand
même son petit truc
là tiens elle a changer ici elle a joué
fa pr C6
et donc un petit pion de
manger mais en fait là j'ai du mal à
défendre le pion c'est ça qui est en
train de me dire F4 est interdit je suis
cloué dam
H5 h G6 g G6 dame
G5 juste c'est grand
ouais ah h c'est pas mal parce
que6 je jouais peut-être ro h F4 quelque
chose comme ça pour bon je sais pas
F4 c'est bizarre les pièces blanches
quand même on sent que pour garder mon
pion je je souffre un petit peu et on va
arriver dans ce que tu disais je pense à
terme voilà F6 ouais pu tu il aura du G5
voilà
ça il faut noir en pratique dans cette
position
bien
pas passe par un échec j'ai pas le droit
deer pas du grand côté en tout cas
comment on fait maintenant avec les les
Noirs tour j'aime
beaucoup
dame 2
G5 3 VO que c'est vraiment décision coup
par coup moi j'aime bien les blancs ou
oui B maintenant qu'elle a joué tour D1
si tu veux moi je pensais qu' tuais
grand rock et attaque deosé je le
sentais pas bien depuis
tour C5 c'est vraiment le coup parce que
il faut jouer des coups hein
c'est une grosse grosse bêtise
stratégique ouais B8 4
probablement ça a l'air d'être terminé
je crois Kevin ouais ouais ouais là ça
c'est en train de prendre l'eau de toute
part en quelques coups vous voyez mais
les les joueuses Harik elle avait pas
envie de se laisser distancer au niveau
du temps donc c'est normal aussi qu'elle
décide d'accélérer en accélérant bah
c'est source d'erreur même pour ces deux
joueuses qui sont grand maîtrre mixte et
extrêmement fortte on les a vu
franchement on a on assiste à très jolie
partie et sous pression du temps elles
font des comme tout le
monde l'agno elle a du temps cette fois
pour convertir le gros avantage et le
roi en E8 c'est une belle galère audelà
d'être moins bien
ouais cavalier B6 et peut-être Dame des
TR ADK et D7 tu as presque pas envie de
faire cavalier B6 ça Vaider tour d V
quoi t peut-être c'est un coup les Noirs
veulent ouais je je pensais faire mange
mange ouais après je prends du roi et je
me cache en ouais je savais pas si tu
étais stable en C7 je sais pas mais je
cavalier A4 ou B6 on va voir on va voir
comment elle joue ça ouais après j'ai
pas envie de manger je peux faire aussi
m tour
B2
Mo du coup logique facile cal 8 le
cavalier à
8 attention pion H2 est-ce que c'est
grave peutre qu'elle va jouer juste H3
H3 elle a le temps ouais H3 G3 G3 bon
c'est même ok al là il P qui est devenu
une cible comment on finit le le
d d c'est bien bon dame
3 le cavalier dire des fois je peux avir
des
ID peutêtre un moment attention quand
même de pas se
[Musique]
prendre ça
çaid pour arver
derrière6 qui tombe bien pour les Noirs
c'est que ça peut être F7 et on a essay
d'envoyer sur le roi c'est chaud mainten
AC une minute c'est toujours pas décisif
loin de
là pas terminer
ça de moins en moins
deééqu
peutêtre
blan
il faut que je joue
peut-être ça j'aime bien ça joli
PR6 ça a
l'airsend mais du
coup bouge
maintenant plus la même et j'ai pas
d'entrée sur cas blanche
malheureusement Mo est-ce que je peux
jouer peut-être
ça1 il y avait k D3 aussi pour jouer5
ouais j'aimis bien k je pense que 5 ça
coup d'avant quand même ça va D3 k D3 E5
ça va l' décisif aussi là mais là
attention j'ai contre jeu contre jeu
éventuel E5 a été joué la jauge qui est
tout en bas ah il y a d B1 et là H3 G4
attends on peut pas jouer G4 on peut
mais il y a dam H1 dans machin il y
A2 alors comment je fais pour finir
ouais après c'est une décision pr pas
mal le problème c'est que j'ai 40
secondes faut que je me Marne ah oui
c'est
cavalier4 la triple fourchette comment
je
problème6 c'est jou ça va être joué K6
[Musique]
ça vite
pour pour nous
aussi ouais perdu autant mais la
position était extrêmement difficile et
les filles qui sont partis en en pause
dans euh dans ce match et je crois que
nous aussi on va partir en pause
d'ailleurs Kevin parce que il n pas de
pub d'ailleurs stouf je voulais te poser
la question il faut il faut c'est pour
ça queon a pas on a pas fait encore et
je va me faire taper sur le doigt si on
vous met pas de de pu j'ai pensé tout à
l'heure et je me suis dit non mais je
savais qu'il y en avait d'autres donc
euh voil ouais comme il y a une pause ça
va et là c'est la dernière po qu'il y a
donc je suis obligé de vous mettre
toutes les pubs Evin rut qui nous dit un
concours de blunder ouais c'est très
chaud avech 30 secondes cha
et on arrive où tout peut se passer
maintenant on aura 25 minutes de folie
avec du 1+ 1 Stouff du 1+ 1 et toujours
ce petit ce petit point d'avance pour
qui est revenu ouais tout à fait ouais
allez je dis tout de suite pe page de
pub donc restez parmi nous et puis à
tout de suite à tout de suite à
[Musique]
tous
et nous sommes de retour avec Kevin qui
n'est pas là si il est là si si je jure
je suis là stouf mais je t'avais mis un
écr noir ouais j'imagine j'imagine tu
m'avais masqué voilà je t'avais masqué
et puis là alors petit résumé rapide euh
il faut aussi que je
vous alors attends robinide qui c'est
exactement la même
config la même config que IFAN kenuk et
oui il s'est fait modérer le pauvre
Arnaud passé pendant pendant la pause je
crois que Robin a mise clic et il a mise
clic parce que le message de de Arnaud
c'est à bientôt
yum tu te fais modérer parce que tu dis
à bientôt Yume c'est beau mais euh et ça
part à l'instant allez donc euh 1+ 1 1+
1 euh avantage euh àka d' point dans ce
match 25 minutes de bullette et une
Anglaise euh première anglaise anglaise
première fois première fois dans ce
match ouais ouais donc 43 on va jouer B4
probblement B4 B5 jouer sur la diagonale
et jouer4 ok voà on
envoieagno qui qui prend le temps là qui
est surprise par l'anglaise et qui prend
son temps alle
attention moi j'ai un jour d'envoyer du
K D4 elle a pas fait bon comment elle va
faire maintenant cavali en le 7 il va
vouloir jeou probablement F5 un jour
Caval H5 F5 cavali H7 F5 5 c'est très
thématique dams attention attention ah
ça marche pas marche pas ouais on aime
bien ce genre de coup mais là ça va
s'accélérer on est parti pour 25 minutes
de
bagarre très intéressant
attention5 intéressant je sais pas trop
sur D5 bah ouais j'ai j'ai le centre
mais tu un passé en tout cas r elle fait
bonne impression et c'est peut-être une
cadence qui lui vient mieux ouais ça
joue vite en tout cas ça joue vite
et faut quand même pas non plus jouer
trop trop vite ni trop lentement il y a
quand même une seconde par coup ça
change tout hein par rapport au normal
c'est la dernière bêtise qui va qui va
faire mal on a vu hein quand les les
jeunes femmes avaient moins d'une minute
à la pendule que ça faisait pas mal de
bêtises forcément dû à la pression du
temps et là on est directement dans ce
cadre là et Catarina lagno qui a été ent
dans l'ouverture et en plus qui souffre
sur les chiquier parce qu'elle a une
position on voit que ses pièces mineur
sont sur TR rangé
je
pas8 intéressant
aussi beaucoup de choses là quand
mmeiss prendre Jes Jes ça fait quand
même
[Musique]
beaucoup
une découverte ça fait
peur plus simple attention 3 secondes en
plus
jou c'est juste perdu c'est juste perdu
il faut abandonner je
pense il faut qu' abandonne pour en
recommencer une le temps presse allez
abandon prière partie elle est obligé de
se refaire quasiment directement là avec
les Blancs
en tout
cas c vous la mauvaise info
désolé le
score j'ai pas vu je me suis laissé
avoir mais ça lui fait mal de défaites
de suite dans ce match
donc as pour l'instant un seul Bull mais
encore minutes minutes
de est possible encore
bien sûr mais ça fait mal pour qui vient
de perdre deux fois de suite elle va
devoir réagir en champion ouais prise
prise elle est là en tout cas elle va
jouer prise ou elle prend G7
intermédiaire H4 H5 peut-être petit un
jour d à l'URE
normale elle laisse
ok t
B8 pour ok tout petit peu mieux
bon va visiter
le c'est un coup très thématique dans
cette position kg8 qui enlève tous les
mat c'est ce qu'elle a fait je cherchais
je cherchais je cherchais quelque chose
il y a cavalier F5 dame D8 qui D6 et et
je cherchais oh là
là pas vu
bon on avait eu l'information j'éis en
train de calculer cavalier F5 et
cavalier H5 sou on a apprécié en tout
cas tu as été écouté par écoute
g les structures un peu pire que tout ça
je connais bien et je sais que c'est un
coup thématique après j'ai pas calculé
pour faire je dis sur souvent bon a
est-ce que ça pourrait être un short ce
momentl B
ouais8 robinide s'en occuper je crois
qu'il est parti robinide malheureusement
il a fait son petit ban et il est parti
direct quoi sinon sinon il serait il
serait tombé à point nommé pour ce kg8
de l'espace 6 ça se passe bien Catarina
avec les pièces blanches bien plus
ambitieuses que dans la première partie
attention alors cavalier mat il y avait
cavalier échec et mat
voilà a ça March aussi donc oui oui là
elle fait une bonne partie mais la
pièces blanche un peu plus facile de
mettre la pression est-ce qu'on peut
prendre le pion D6 voilà c'est fait
c'est pris et maintenant continue il y a
quand même des ménages un peu partout
là c'est un coup c'est un coup très
adapté à la situation avec l'avantage
tour D1 peutê peutêtre des
découvertes c'est chaud ouais tour D1
c'est plus sage oui non c'est clair là
tu es tu es beaucoup mieux il faut
avancer tranquillement quoi attention
faut faut pas oublier la variable temps
cavalier ah les pièces sont
bizarres cavalier mais ça va trop vite
allez change change FO c'est pas mal x 2
c'est un bon coup D5 peut-être B2 c'est
pas mal Caval D5 al qu Mme pas mal hein
ah il f prend ouais bêtis tour D7 j'aime
bien tour F7 c'est fait non tour7 je
peux pas ah non je peux pas du
tout j'ai cru hein mais moi aussi mais
j'ai vu le cavalier fa dire cétais à
deux Doig de le dire comme toi tout à
l'heure vous voyez hein à chaque coup
les jauges maintenant oh là là attention
d prendam tour à H ça va mais ça se
rééquilibre complètement ouais quand
même ce cavalier qui est hors de hors du
combat allez il faut faut vite protéger
G2 est-ce qu'on fait tour à 2 estceon B3
est-ce qu'on fait ro roi H1 tour G1
c'est très passif
c'estit mat ou quoi H4
elle va tomber elle va tomber va tomber
tour à 2
il faut pas tomber ici G3 c'est pris H4
incroyable a a a a hopro et voilà a AE a
a a dur dur elle a avait dominé toute la
partie Catarina lagno elle elle voit
plus
rien on voit qu'elle
est et là on est à 17 plus 3 maintenant
ça reste encore
possible mais c'est pas évident arrive
plus elle est fatigué
aussi c pas cétait pas son match parce
que généralement quand même elle nous
habitue à mieux
a fait pas mal d'reur tactique
ou oui j'ai l'impression que ou pu c'est
difficile donc
là se rappellera forcément ce moment où
normalement les trois points d'avance
sont pris et ça peut être la défaite et
maintenant est-ce qu'elle va réussir à
réagir ouais à plus 4 la condamnerai on
peut penser à ce moment-là du du match
parce que même si c'est du du 1 plus 1
si elle se retrouve avec autant de
retard c'est
foutu il y avait la place pourtant pour
elle hein clairement
et en plus la elle a été assez maline
elle joue vite elle a toujours 5 minutes
et puis elle a choisi un début plan plan
très solide l elle a av
donc si la partie dure longtemps ça
l'arrange parce que elle gagne du temps
en fait aussi un combat contre la montre
de retard complètement et 16 minutes
donc plus la partie
plus voit que sous pression du temps
souvent fait des boulettes et là c'est
mine de rien regarde SF avec l'idée tour
tour à 7 ça peut être vraiment vraiment
chiant F5 sur peut-être B5 je pense
ouais C5 par contre c'est chaud C5 je me
débarrasser de mes faiblesse peutêtre
alors là je mange de
quoi les deux étaient joua mais en tout
cas ouais là c'est pe-être une petite
contrechance quand même pour les pour
les noirs qui dans cette partie me sa
pas
ouais on peut faire on peut jou je
pensais qu' jouer pour tour B1 match nul
ça c'est un peu risqué parce que si on p
le
pion ou tu as
raisonuc comme
ça tu
vasettisis va pouvoirer les
P tu
veux
pas
tac oui ro F7 important pour tour 8
ouais ça aurait été le drame
autrement
C3
et maintenant j'arrive pas
àendut- t B5 d'abord quand même c encore
C tu la pouss encore un peu t B7 B5
direct ouais tu la pousse quand même
parce que le le roi blanc mine de rien
il est un peu passif le bien aimé hein
ça empêché
5 maintenant je sais pas si tu veux la
gagner réussir à faire tour là tour là
rentrer avec la tour
ouais ça va pousser a tour ici RAM elle
est trop mal au temps elle est trop mal
au temps ouais ou le roi qui rentre
ouais mais est-ce que ça suffira c'est
pas sûr parce que est très faible ouais
je peux même faire tour ici er manger le
P h H5 peut-être ça vachanger
je pensais qu'elle allait peut-être
tenter H5 pour on essayer de c'est n ok
une belle nulle bien maîtrisée avec les
blancs de et ça joue ah oui ah oui oui
oui l'orreur ça j'aime pas ça mais
ouais ça devrait faire nul mais euh mais
elle veut gagner du temps bah ça fait
partie du jeu non ça fait partie du jeu
elles le font toutes hein mais pas TR
voir ça mais ça me plaît pas trop maisou
allez là c'est il faut ah oui
oui par qu'elle a joué quand même plus
vite bon après si a même moins de temps
bon voyez un AR la plus 3 donc
évidemment après c'est une compétition
c'est parti elle elle joue pour les
règles et tout ça c'est h c'est s que
c'est ballot on se le prend moi ça
m'énerverait bien mais bon
ouais c'est la vie ouais c'est ça en
fait comme c'est le règlement et
d'ailleurs j'ai envie de dire la
première personne qui a commencé
vraiment à faire ça c'était gritou h HM
c'est le mari de Catharina Lano pour
ceux qui ne savent pas et du coup bon
bon c'est les règles c'est les règles tu
as le droit ouais c'est ça
or autorisé ouais je sais pas si ou pas
j'en sais rien non mais en fait autant
le faire parce que si si après on le
fait voilà c'est pas ouais
il la règle des 50 coups de toute façon
pour
ça mais c'est vrai que c'est pas le
moment le plus tordant de ce speed chess
voilà on attend la r des 50
coups
et a changer les tour a bien bloqué il
reste 13 minutes plus
3 ça va être chaud quand même est-ce
qu'elle a le temps de revenir matériel
c'est pas sûr elle peut déjà presque
avoir perdu allez ça fait nul
C tu sais juste en résistant si elle
résiste une fois ouais aura gagné en
fait il faudrait que là il il faut
vraiment que Carina de prochaines et
essaie de commencer au moins la 3è ouis
ou tu as raison tu as raison on va
voirement elle peut encore largement
revenir tout à fait mais on a compris
queikelle a l'occasion elle va faire
durer ça on a
compris pourtant elle a joué une
ouverture assez risquée bah après je
pense sais quand tu joues quand tu t
préparé pour le mach même si tu es en
train de gagner est-ce que changer de de
de technique hein non bien sûr mais elle
avait
plusieurs plusieurs ouvertures à
disposition dans le match par qu'elle a
alterné on lui a vu la française on a vu
aussi sa ligne contre l'Espagnol h
franchement c'est c'est pas la plus
grande réussite généralement quand elle
fait ça elle se peut prend une bonne
racé gr problème là gros problème sur
sur G6 tu manges quand même
lui laisse une dernière chance j'ai même
cavalier F4 encore plus fort F4 je
préfère ouais bon je préférais qu' F4
mais t pr G6 ça pour être mauvais ouais
c'est bien att il y a dame G3 qui peut
arriver aussi Ohou là qu'est-ce que
c'est que çaine là complètement
aussi3 ah ok il a une belle idée prend à
3 mais F prend à 3 ça devrait aller bon
tout reprendre des cartes c'est ok
aussi fou D3 la chose j'aime pas du tout
pourquoi d B4 peut-être non je pas de
menace moi j'aurais pris à TR je sais
pas pourquoi oua ouais c'était normal pr
à3 tu fou
B2 fou à3 bon ça a ét ça a été
joué et le dame B4 c'est c'était sans
doute la la solution pour laisser un peu
de pressing
ouais dame B4 et C5 C4 un truc du style
quoi mais bon là il faut quand même
faire un peu attention c'est pas si
simple humainement euh oua oui c'est
sans doute complètement gagnant la jauge
nous le dit mais effectivement comme
nous disent Stouff ben il y a un peu de
travail
fou
G6 il peut y avoir tactique parce qu'on
a 30 secondes les gagnant et on peut la
dame D4 qui bloque
tout galère à trouver nous aussi Stouff
pousser un pas mal faire revivre ce fou
je pense qu'elle a trouvé un très très
bon coup
ok est-ce qu'on ferait pas fou3 pour
soulager dame D2 2 prochainement dame F6
bien joué ça marche pas
d4chè bien joué encore dame D2 voilà
bien joué la bonne séquence dame D5 k D6
attention fou D4 sans doute on peut se
faire caroter attention dame
C1 était possible aussi Dame des de
peut-être ah oui fou B6 oh le fou B6 a a
ça y est juste sur le final alors
qu'elle é en train peut-être de
s'empétrer dans une partie difficile et
là va essayer de continuer mais se
prend5 se prend pas5 elle aurait d
mais donner
points yes coco j'ai oublé de les
don il est sûr maintenant qu'
elle peut
gagnerz
8 points à 10 et demi il reste 8 minutes
50 dans ce match
8 et demi 10 et demi
ouais c'est
franchement il y en a qui ont
gagné pas
mal bien joué coco pas oublier alors d'A
d'ailleurs on
pe est-ce que je non je pense ça va pas
être faire si je
fais la prédiction je fais une
prédiction si elle gagne cette partie là
Catarina si elle gagne cette partie je
fais une prédiction parce qu'il y aura
de là du coup c'est prédiction
maintenant
c'est qu'est-ce qu'elle a vu
kv4 ça en fait là c'est juste du en
bulette c'est quand même
j'avais dame 7
peut-être bon B là on va voir une partie
un peu un peu pénible pour Catarina
lagno qui a joué plus vite mais qui n'a
pas obtenu grand-chose avec les noirs on
peut comprendre mais en tout cas la
position promet d'être pas très rigolote
ouais mais bon c'est du
bulettein dubulette ça peut vite tourner
regarde cavalier H5 déjà ouis ouais il
faut essayer de faire des petites
plaisir quandême cavalier H5
ouais c'est bien bonne idée est-ce qu'on
peut pas jouer cavalier D 5 H6 fou le 7
pour
B8 on peut tout échanger bon vous voyez
hein qu' joue son rôle elle va essayer
de résister le plus longtemps
ouais très solide mais après il rest enc
7 minutes donc même cette partie c'est
le ST ouais de toute façon après quand
même euh ouais mais là elle elle veut
résister et si elle fait nul elle a
gagné tu vois h ouais ok bon après avec
ce tempsl comme ça encore peut-être
encore deux parties derrière je sais
pas cavalier prend le de
ah
il et défaite sans doute de Catharina
lagno ouais là il faut abandonner he
peut-être tu continues là ouais chance
de de de faire nul comm c'est qu' avit
c'est perdu hein non non mais c'est
perdu serait à moin 3 c'est perdu dans
les deux cas si ouis is là elle vient de
je CIS que raté encore mais elle a été
euh pourquo bon peut-être qu'il y aura
nul d'ailleurs mais nul longue
maintenant tu vois
elle a Monné elle peut elle pecore
manger H3 essayer de faire n he ah ouais
ouais ouais oui là c'est zéro chance
hein ben là c'est perdu je crois plus 3
c'est zéro chance donc du cou a juste à
jouer
longtemps tu continues jusqu'au mat à
chaque fois et ça devrait
suffire 5 minutes 50 dans ce match avec
Mo- 3 là il f gagné deux d'affilé et
commencer la 3è ça ça me paraît dur
parce que niveau temps je sais pas si on
aura on aura le temps de je pense que
ceux qui avaient prédit la victoire
d'Arik vendredi vont pester tu vois non
mais bon euh ben moi j'avais dit hein
j'avais dit c des réclamations j'avais
dit que c'était pasticair ouais on a une
petite Catarina je
pense 90 % c'est beaucoup 90 % qu c'est
beaucoup je suis d'accord avec surtout
au vu de ce qui s passé matchme ass
Close en
fait ok c'est quandme c'est 2550
quasiment les
de un peu moins pour
mais un match
incrment il y a du F4 peut-être
ouis mais avait sur cavalier H4 je crois
qu'il y avait F4 no ou possible et je
crois que
ça possible de toute façon il y a de la
fatigue dans ce match hein franchement
quand vous accumulez autant de parties
euh vous imaginez bien que vous êtes un
peu un peu
crevé il y a eu beaucoup de choses qui
ont mis les les nerfs des des deux
jeunes femmes à à rue d'épreuve et
maintenant c'est un peu biaisé Harik
elle a juste envie de tenir et ça peut
la faire un petit peu
déjouer bon c'est quand même plus 3 hein
+ 3
il reste vraiment du
temps vraiment peu de temps pardon 4
minutes 4 minutes ouais ça a l'air
pensea celle-là et une autre et et même
si gagne les deux il manquera du coup
juste commencer l'autre quoi h tout à
fait on doit juste jouer pas faire de
grosses bêtises P elle hy solide elle
prend pas de risque hein cette partie
elle répète elle essaie de elle sait que
que
il reste pas grandchose et elle bétonne
elle essaie de tenir le plus longtemps
possible c'est déjà pas faire de bêtises
ouais et c'est dur pour pour Catharina
lagno qui est souvent mal au temps et là
en plus sa position elle est vraiment
casse gueule parce que le le roi blanc
est très faible h donc elle pourrait
s'incliner dame F3 très bien joué fa un
seul coup
g4ance pour F5 voilà pour F5 pas mal de
coups qui peuvent8 F8 bon peut
jouer par contre c'était euh pas prévu
si moi je défends chez moi non mais
peut-être c'est pas très grave on peut
rester au contact
du du cavalier D3 dame
F5 ça y est ça a été rendu pour essayer
de pimenter un petit peu ouais 3 minutes
à la pendule ouais c'est chaud c'est
chaud parce que a pas abandonné hein une
partie qui va durer enc elle doit tenir
elle va durer encore un petit moment
cette partie au moins 30 bonnes secondes
même plus au moin plus je
pense une partie je pense que de une
plus une ça dure environ 5 minutes que
ça dure longtemps 4 5
donc mais ça va la faire un peu suer à
Ricard de paumer si Catarina confirme
pense qu'elle s'en fout
ais mais parce que il faut pas stresser
sur la dernière quoi
[Musique]
ouais je pense qu'elle sera soulagé
quand parce qu'elle a quand même filé
une pièce en un donc il doit y avoir de
la
fatigue là tu as l'impression quand même
que là ou là voilà il fallait finir a a
a c'est bon là c'est fini là c'est fini
moi je sais pas il peut y avoir un
revirement ave le voilà c'est en train
de de de mal se passer avec la tour en
plus pour montrer un petit peu le truc
tu sais c'est incroyable elle laisse
laisse la tour en un coup elle va quand
même gagner la partie ou pas besoin de
la tour j'eni pas besoin de la
tour c'est quoi une tour au déch ça sert
à quoi
elle a raté
F passer ou c'est l'autre pion peut-être
mais bon là tu C6 tu pousse ouais ouais
elle va gagner ça va rester il va rester
plus que une minute en plus ça va pas
gagner oh là oh là regarde
gagn gagne pas ouis
ok allez VO bon il reste plus qu'une
minutes dans ce
[Musique]
match dernière
partie et tr points à remonter en ouais
en en une
partie des bêtis sur la fin puis là on
est désabusé
forcément forcément elle est
plus plus
satisfaite que Catharina lagno qui
forcément et un peu d'IG
ouais donc là c'est vraiment pour le
pour le
plaisir pour le plaisir de l'une ouais
pour le plaisir de l'une bien bien dis
l'autre je pense que pr un peu moins de
plaisir ici dans ce mat ou oui puis on
on rappelle il y a quand même des des
gâs financiers important oui donc c'est
c'est quand même puis a l'aspect sportif
aussi c'est toujours dur de perdre comme
ça es un joueur au fond donc tu as pas
envie de perdre même si tu
vois c'est clair que il y a des Blitz
plus informels sur Internet et là quand
même c'est c'est une belle compétition
ouais l'occasion de de jouerifan les
deux jeunes femmes peuvent gagner
contreifan donc pouveit
remporter et maintenant pe surprise dans
ceoui même si euh je j'avais moi je
l'avais pas enterré du tout à
complement mais c'est vrai que Catarina
était quand même favorite dans ce
match mais moi je la voyais je la voyais
beaucoup plus propre que
çaik dans son style de jeu mais elle
elle a arrive aussi comme toute tous les
grands maîtres mixtes à faire muter son
style et être beaucoup
plus on va dire tactique bist dans son
approche quand il le faut
contbour terminé donc après cette partie
c'est ce sera fini et donc on rappelle
que la finale c'est demain à
13h
donc drone
contre donc 13h parce qu'en Chine et ben
il sera sera déjà tard et c'est pour
queil y a un horaire où tout le monde à
peu près peut trouver son compte elle
fait une sale dernière partie
d'ailleurska pour fêter sa
victoire qu'elle sait qu'elle a gagné
c'est décract et c'est pas facile
et alors est-ce que demain elle peut
prétendre battre IFAN je pense que oui
parce queifan n'avait pas été souveraine
non plus jusqu'au bullettes é mais c'est
vrai quand même que il y a quand même eu
beaucoup de fautes dans ce match
contrairement au match quand même de
genou
an il y a eu des erreurs tactiques et
tout mais je ouais il y a plus de
constance dans l'autre match là je pense
que Catarina lagno a joué en dessous de
de son niveau ouais et
etavali a bien profité mais du coup
an c'est quand même pas le genre à
donner des pièces à faire TR de blunder
et du coup je pense que d C2 a tour pr
G2 si elle
si elle joue comme aujourd'hui elle
risque de perd le match quand Mme
demain il y avait d' pr de c'était cool
avec prend C c'est pas mal non plus
encore mieux bon là c'est bon tu peux
abandonner au lie de tomber le temps
tomber au cas où on sait jamais si il
arriv je me laisse bien tomber voilà
alors rapidement je vais vous montrer
[Musique]
le ont pases ont pas nécessairement le
Chono tu sais ouais ou ou du coup elle a
eu peur tu sais mais je pense qu'elle
peuvent l'avoir parce que tu peux voir
ton adversaire sur votre écran je sais
pas trop donc le bracket qui arrive ici
en finale on a ouifan qui a gagné qui a
terrassé tous ses adversaires et Arika
qui vient de gagner la demi-finale
contre Caterina Lano et qui va se
retrouver demain à 13h en finale contre
ouifan ouifan c'était champion du monde
je crois à 17 ans euh très spectaculaire
a a ouais après elle a pris un peu sa
retraite chez Ken parce que elle a
choisi les études tout simplement mais
bon
fan elle avait à 18 ans à peu près 2680
quoi hein donc quasiment 2700 lo c'est
quand même très costaud même si elle
trop au échecs elle est quand même
encore tout à fait là regardz ben quand
même sorti chuvalova sur un gros score
cost sur un petit score OK et maintenant
ou les demi étaient chaudes les demi
étaaient chaud on a eu la chance avec C
dem à commenter avec des des scores très
serrés par rapport au quart franchement
les deux demi étaient quand même
passionnantes même s'il y a eu des
erreurs forcément avec des cadences mais
c'était cool quand même à commenter
ouais voilà donc en tout cas pour notre
part je pense hein Kevin on va s'arrêter
là yes et puis et demain 1h demain 13h
grosse finale entre Arik et ouifan donc
gros gros match et et merci à tous
d'avoir suivi le stream ah merci à toi
pour ta disponibilité Kevin bah avec
plaisir toi c'est pareil puisque vous
savez qu'on était là vendredi quand on a
fait ben chou blanc avec avec ce stream
de des demi-finales donc là on est
revenu à la charge et demain c'est la
grande finale demain on vous attendoup
àh pour ceux qui peuvent venir parce que
effectivement l'horaire n'arrange pas
tout le monde mais il faut s'arranger
vous savez he
an c'est une joueuse chinoise euh donc
on a dronavali la joueuse indienne donc
faut arranger tous beau monde au niveau
de l'international ouais c'est
ça bon B
super je à demain 13h et et vous tous
aussi nombreux que vous pouvez être yes
à demain merci à tous ciao ciao ok salut
à
bientôt